foreign
yes
good morning it's great to see all of
we have a very special guest starting
the day Jason Huang is senior vice
president strategic planning and
research at Federal Home Loan Bank of
Boston he oversees the bank's strategic
planning process and provides management
and the board of directors with
financial forecasts
an assessment of strategic opportunities
and risks Jason also supervises Research
into the bank's performance and broader
banking industry Trends he holds a PhD
in economics from Harvard University and
speaks frequently about the economy and
federal Home Loan Bank of Boston
throughout New England so Jason thank
you so much for being here today thank
you very much Madam chair members of the
committee it's an honor to be here uh
with you this morning to discuss the
economy so thank you for having me so
I'm here to provide economic update and
let me just quickly go through some
topics for today this being my first
time coming before this group wanted to
just tell you a little bit about myself
and the organization I work for and then
the main topic of the day uh wanted to
focus on inflation that being the
critical driver of economic performance
uh this coming year and uh key policy
choices that uh the Federal Reserve will
have to make all depends on what happens
with inflation this year so that'll be
the focus of my comments today so I'd
list here kind of six things that have
contributed to kind of the very high
levels of inflation that we've seen
so just to give you a quick preview what
are the six things
supply chain bottlenecks that's number
one number two is the war in Ukraine
leading to a big increase in Energy
prices number three relaxation of covet
restrictions leading to a surge in
demand for travel
number four is household savings uh
becoming very high during the pandemic
number five is home prices and number
six is a labor shortage which I know you
discussed with some of the State labor
economists yesterday afternoon so I'll
make some comments about that as well
and then I'll make some comments about
Federal Reserve policy and provide an
outlook on the US economy and make some
comments about the New England economy
okay
I look so we have a question up front
representative plett
yes I didn't I noticed that you didn't
mention the amount of cash circulating
the the inflation is from uh
overspending by the federal government
uh I'll come to that I think that'll be
related to the topic of excess savings
uh that will come to I would remind
members that this is not a place for you
to make statements about your beliefs
this is a place for you to ask very
polite clarifying questions of our
presenters thank you
thank you
oh
um
yes
representative fellows
um yeah I'm just wondering if you could
if you're going to or can you
um Define what you mean by inflation is
there a particular metric I certainly
can't yes
can I come to that in in two minutes all
right I'll start Michael remarks on that
let me start tell you a little bit about
myself so uh as Madam chair just
mentioned I am Senior vice president of
strategic planning and research at the
Federal Bank of Boston and
um I get to do this at industry events
and with our member institutions
throughout New England
so the organization I work for I wanted
to just tell you a little bit
um in 2022 last year we celebrated our
20th year anniversary
um we are a wholesale Bank lending to
member institutions throughout New
England
and it happens it just happens that the
longest member that has been with us and
has been using our services is a New
Hampshire member a Salem cooperative
bank and they've been a member of our
Organization for almost 90 years and
soon it'll be 100 years so on the next
page you see here the institutions who
are members of the federal Home Bank of
Austin just about every Community Bank
and uh many of the larger credit unions
and many of the insurance companies are
members of our cooperative and they use
us for their liquidity and funding
purposes and many organizations use us
for affordable housing programs as well
in Community Development
okay with that uh background out of the
way here let's get to the topic so very
good question what do we mean by
inflation here
so when we talk about inflation we're
talking about the general price level so
when we talk about the general price
level we're talking about households
consumption baskets so uh each of us
represent a household and we all have
consumption baskets we consume goods and
services Goods including things like
food apparel things that we buy services
like Medical Services
transportation services uh and things
things like mortgage payments are
considered Services as well so all those
have price levels associated with them
and economists at the Bureau of Labor
Statistics work hard to bring all those
prices into a single metric and that's
the general consumption price index and
then when we talk about inflation we're
talking about how much did that general
price level change year over year
do that help okay okay so on that point
before uh at 8 30 this morning uh right
before uh we started this session there
was a the newest uh Consumer Price
inflation report was released and uh I
don't know if you're like economists
looking for this report every month and
you know five minutes in you you've kind
of reviewed all the data in case you
have not
um I was looking for the report and I
saw it right after it came out let me
just tell you that there's good news so
Consumer Price inflation peaked at 9.1
percent in June of this year
the latest reading for December is 6.5
so it's been trending in the in the
right direction but arguably it is still
too high and the quick quite the
question is
uh how quickly will it come down to the
Federal reserve's target of two percent
inflation per year
so that that's kind of what I want to
provide some
um perspective on on a core basis
because prices of food prices of energy
can be quite volatile sometimes the BLS
will track core inflation numbers
excluding food and energy prices and
that came in at 5.7 year-over-year
change
an improvement over a peak of 6.6
so headline inflation has come down from
Peak numbers earlier uh in the middle of
last year and then on a core basis
inflation has come down as well so
encouraging signs but these levels are
still much too high uh if you talk to
any of the FED officials the target is
is closer to a two percent level so
anything about five or six or those are
very high numbers and they're looking to
bring those numbers down
okay so to provide perspective on how
these numbers are trending whether we're
likely to see substantial moderation in
inflation numbers I just I thought that
it might help if we just walk through
each of the reasons why inflation has
been so high over the past year and then
kind of look at some data that might
point us to uh some Trends and and that
could help us notice some patterns okay
so let's start with the first
uh reason here which is the supply chain
issue in the middle of 2021 I like many
uh Americans were was working fully from
home working totally remotely not going
to the office at all and I wanted a
little bit of a nicer home office so I
went to a furniture store to buy a new
couch and the salesperson told me after
I pointed out one that I liked okay
you're looking at six months for that to
get delivered to your house because the
factory in Vietnam is shut down and even
if they come back online and start
manufacturing their sofas it'll take a
very long time for that to get here
because of the bottleneck in Supply
chains and delivery times having
increased a lot so one example of that
is this news article from uh late 2021
where outside the LA Port which accepts
about 30 of All Imports coming into the
United States they were close to a
hundred ships they were unable to Dock
and unload their cargo and so that just
you know it's like right outside it's
here the ships have come here arrived
and yet they're because of the supply
chain issues labor shortage issues uh
they were unable to unload their cargo
so that kind of thing Supply constrained
supply and demand if if it's strong
that'll tend to raise prices of these
Goods kind of coming into the country
so what's happened since then to the
backlog of container ships and cargo
ships so this is a a chart that shows
the number of uh ships waiting to dock
at the LA Port and again that's one of
the most important ports for imports
coming into the country and what it
shows is that throughout 2021 things got
progressively worse with the number of
ships that are waiting uh Rising
throughout the year and it got to kind
of the peak level over 100 ships waiting
to uh come into the port in the early
part of 2022 about a year ago when it
was when it was at the kind of the worst
peak of this problem
but the good news here is that
throughout 2022 this problem has really
eased and if you look at the kind of the
most recent data points for October it
shows that uh We've almost solved this
problem we don't have nearly as many
ships that are activating uh to dock at
the the LA Port so uh very good news and
so this is uh seems like this issue is
really in the rear view mirror here in
terms of causing supply chain
bottlenecks and causing uh putting
pressures on inflation
it turns out that this story is actually
part of a broader Global story which is
very positive supply chain pressures
across the world are easing which is
great for uh inflation so because this
issue has become very important uh for
uh prices and and pressures on inflation
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York has
been tracking this new index
which they call the global supply chain
pressure index based on two things one
thing is how much does it cost
to ship something let's say I have a
manufacturing facility in Shanghai and I
finish making uh something there and
then I want to ship it to the US how
much does it cost
so that's one thing they track and the
other thing is how long does it take and
so it takes into account things like uh
backlogs at La ports and and things of
that nature so the higher this number
the worse the problem the higher this
number the worse the pressures on Supply
chains and the more expensive it is the
longer it takes to bring Goods into the
US the lower it is the better the the
dark horizontal line at zero represents
the historical average and what it shows
is that throughout the pandemic we've
really had supply chain challenges
almost from the get-go due to lockdowns
in many places around the world
especially in China where a lot of
manufacturing happens as well as the
challenges with delivery and other
supply chain issues and it really peaked
in the about a year ago in the first uh
quarter of 2022 but again good news this
problem has been getting better
throughout 2022 so delivery time is
coming down cost is coming down so these
are all kind of relieving some pressure
on inflation on this front
okay so that's the first reason supply
chain so I think this is good news if
this is the only thing that was going on
and this is the only thing that was
driving inflation I think we would not
have an inflation problem going forward
so this is good news here
um let's go to the next issue which is
energy and commodity prices so as we all
know uh June of last year 2022 is when
gas prices peaked uh national average
right a little above five dollars and I
think it was above five dollars here in
New Hampshire and then throughout New
England as well the photo here shows at
California where there's the prices are
much higher
okay so what how has the the trend
looked uh so far so the big increase
came uh in the early part of 2022
following uh Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Russia being a major exporter of
both uh crude oil and a natural gas so
those uh sanctions placed on them and so
on so that put a lot of pressure on this
market and prices uh sharply increased
in uh the earlier part of 2022 reaching
a peak uh just above five dollars
average Across the Nation in June of
this year but as we know as we know from
kind of watching and then filling up at
gas stations that price has come down
quite a bit uh and and we're right now
we're at the low threes uh and uh so
that's a very positive trend so there's
a downward uh Trend here uh and uh that
the important thing here remember that
when I Defined inflation at the very
beginning it's an annual metric that the
FED is targeting so compared to the same
time last year where our price is today
so it's not so let's say gas prices
today are 320 per gallon so that's still
high compared to pre-pandemic but that's
not what we're measuring we're measuring
compared to a year ago where price is
today and and if you look at this chart
here and you track sort of where things
were a year ago were lower today uh a
year ago gas prices were even higher
than 320 or wherever we are now so uh
that would represent a positive
development if so year over year gas
prices even though the level is high the
change from last year might be uh uh in
the right direction meaning it's low or
even possibly even negative
so there would tend to be a positive
factor for inflation
okay that was gasoline prices the other
important
um
energy uh source of course is
electricity
and electric electricity prices have
risen through for most of 2022
but they did reach a peak in September
and the most recent data I have are for
October and November and prices did come
down for those two months so again
positive news there would love to see
electric prices come down further but at
least uh you know it's a little or too
early to call this a trend but at least
uh for the most two recent months we
have data for things are moving in the
right direction there and hopefully uh
we did see a peak there
could we interrupt for just a moment
absolutely there's a representative
behind you representative McGuire has a
question
and we're heading into the winter season
so a lot of natural gas gets diverted to
Heating
should we expect electricity prices to
go up more
so that's an excellent question so
representative's exactly right
electricity prices have a lot to do with
natural gas prices so I didn't show here
but I also took a look at at natural gas
prices so natural gas prices do not show
a shop increase as as of right now and
what they're expected to going forward I
think it's a little hard to tell it
depends on the severity of the weather
how cold it gets in the winter here in
in other parts of the world so far it's
been a mild winter that's helped uh so I
think that would that would drive a lot
of the short-term movements and beyond
that I think uh kind of the geopolitical
things kind of come into play there
what's happening in Ukraine and Russia
and so on so but at least so far we
haven't seen a kind of a big rise that
would tell us that uh you know a big
rise in electricity prices are coming so
far thank you
you're welcome
representative elberger thank you madam
chair I wonder if you could uh give us
some specific information
concerning uh utility prices electrical
prices uh in New Hampshire and
particularly as compared to the rest of
the region
um
that I don't have data up where I'm
sorry I I don't have specific data on
YouTube the prices for the state as well
but I I would think that there are some
state-specific factors but I would
imagine these general price movements
happening Across the Nation even across
the world are a big part of what would
drive state level data as well but there
might be some specific State specific
factors that I haven't looked at
carefully thank you thank you madam
chair there's another representative
behind you behind the screen to
act would help drop the pressure on our
electricity right yeah I think I think
that's a that's a big question
um I I think a waiver of the Jones act
in my view so that that's a kind of
there's a political issue there too but
it might be a very positive thing for
yes right right I think at the purely
purely from an economic perspective I
think it would make it easier to
transport things within this within the
nation and it would I think reduce
okay
um what about food so Ukraine Russia is
a major exporter of oil and uh um
natural gas Ukraine is number five or
six
um in the world in terms of exports of
of uh wheat and corn
um and so we did see a sharp rise in uh
food commodity prices I'm showing here
the price of corn in blue and the price
of wheat in red uh so a big increase uh
in fact there's there was a trend
preceding even The Invasion uh in early
2022 but there was a sharp rise
following the invasion in February of 22
uh
so the levels are high but again good
news here I think there was a a big drop
off in the price of wheat in as you can
see in red there and the price of corn
seems to have stabilized it did rise but
then uh more stable
so if I'm trying to project inflation
going forward
this this is going to say that for some
time you know if you compare to like a
year ago it's going to reflect that big
increase that that's happened but uh you
know it is now January it'll soon be
February and March and and we're gonna
get past the period when we saw the big
increase in the early part of 22 and at
that point the year-over-year change is
not going to be as dramatic so I was I
would think that as long as the trends
continue here this is going to represent
a moderating force on inflation
so again a sort of a positive story so
the general story there is that energy
and food prices by the way
um
when you when you construct this uh
inflation metric by looking at household
consumption baskets The crucial thing is
how much weight do you put on different
components like how how much do
households spend on the various
components of this basket that we're
talking about
food is is 13 it changes uh from time to
time
so that's a pick that we spent a lot of
money at grocery stores you know buying
food for our families energy is about
nine percent so that's uh you know us
you know filling up our uh cars
and so together it's a little over 20.
and so that's that's a fifth of of the
whole basket there and so what happens
to these prices are very important for
inflation and the general story is yes
they did contribute very substantial to
inflation over the past year but going
forward it seems that as long as the
current trends continue that they will
uh
be a moderating force in inflation going
moving on
did anyone have travel plans canceled
for over the past three years
I had a big international trip planned
for April 2020 of course we have to
cancel that and then we thought okay
we're not going to travel
internationally but let's do a national
parks uh trip to Utah and Nevada and
even that somehow we ended up scheduling
during the one of the waves or something
so that got canceled uh and so we're
looking to schedule maybe a bigger trip
this year
um and I imagine others of you might
have done something similar as well but
so big news last year was that this
thing called Revenge travel uh where
because we're kind of stuck at home not
able to travel for some time folks were
eager to kind of get out and travel
domestically and internationally so that
represented huge demand for things like
air travel uh transportation services uh
cars and things like that and there was
a question as to how much of that was
driving uh inflation in those sectors
so here's a chart here so what's shown
in blue is the price of airfares and
what's shown in red is the price of
lodging so the price of staying at
hotels and so on
so what do you see here
um what you see is that in the uh middle
of 2021 there is that bump that you see
kind of the smaller bump uh in the
middle of 2021 so there was summer of
2021 after being at home for a full year
and more people were wanting to get out
and there was a sort of significant
demand for travel
um and and then but then in in the
summer of 22 about six months ago is
when this really took off and airfares
were increasing at very dramatic rates
and contributed substantial to inflation
so two things happened that really
exacerbated this issue one was people
wanted to travel more uh there was
demand for air error uh travel was high
at the same time what's the biggest cost
of Airlines fuel prices and of course
somewhere of 22 is when gas prices were
therapeutic oil prices went their Peak
and this this was a tough uh time to
sort of manage fuel costs and so
Airlines responded by raising prices a
lot
so in my family it's sometimes once
every few years traveled to the West
Coast to see family and usually all five
of us go but last year we saw the
airfares and they were double uh what we
would have expected even considering
that it was summer time so only two of
us ended up traveling instead of five so
uh we lost a little bit of GDP we had
all five of us traveled we would have
contributed more to National output than
than we did with just two of us
traveling so airfares increased
dramatically in 22
eye-popping levels they were like
doubling uh or more and
um but what about now so that happened
what about now so that's the critical
issue here and if you look at the
pattern of the Blue Line since about
June of 22 it's been coming down okay so
if you do it year over year on this
number what is it's going to say that
year over year it's still a very
positive high high change it's it's a
very inflationary sector because
compared to a year ago airfares are much
much higher
but
at some point this year we're going to
get past that period when that big
change happened and at that point we're
going to be in that downward portion if
the trend continues past June of 22
we're gonna eventually the year over
year calculation will cover that period
and then we're going to see moderation
inflation if not an outright decline in
airfares in the price level and that'd
be very positive for inflation
hotel prices shown in the red line uh
also increased starting in the middle of
21 but not quite as dramatically and
they've stabilized so we're not seeing
these big increases in hotel prices
lodging uh prices as we did for airfare
so that seems positive positive again if
you do kind of a year over year change
it's going to show a little bit of a
excuse me representative almie has a
question yes please thank you I'm afraid
I should have asked this in the second
previous segment but on in other parts
of the world
on food is a lot larger part of the
budget than it is here and in other
parts of the world the cost of fuel is a
lot higher than it is here yes and on
we've we're coming through a period when
we don't know where we're going to end
up but at what point do you start
looking at the Market Basket again and
decide okay food is a larger part of the
budget or energy is a larger part of the
budget very good question I think uh
your comments about uh internationally
that basket looking different are spot
on I think the our basket reflects kind
of the wealth of this nation and and
what it what it is that we're able to
spend uh kind of our income on so we
spent far more on travel Services uh and
things like that than other countries
might so the basket would look really
different if you did an international
comparison but even even within the US
the basket
could and would change uh just over time
and I think that's that's part of the
the updates that the the Bureau of Labor
Statistics does I think on a monthly
representative soti has a question yes
thank you um does the lodging portion do
you include the Airbnb in those type of
uh I I had the same question does Airbnb
get included in this I don't know the
answer to that it will definitely
include traditional lodging places
I would think that Airbnb has been
around long enough and and uh important
enough that but I I don't know the
specific answer there I should look into
it
representative Jen again has a question
thank you madam chair
um thank you for taking our questions uh
you had mentioned that energy was about
nine percent of the basket uh cost uh
for for a household I'm wondering uh do
you know what percent energy is of the
um so that's a good question when I say
nine percent that's about consumer uh
consumption basket personal consumption
expenditures how much of that goes to
you know gas and electricity when you
ask how much of the US economy is energy
that's a different question that's like
how much of GDP is attributable to the
energy producing sector uh and so on
um
I don't have I don't have the number off
the top of my head there
um and um
I'll have to get back to you on that one
okay thank you
I see lots of questions representative
orders
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so we're talking
about the weights of the items in the
basket and my financial advisor tells me
that the items that affect us most on a
day-to-day basis is about 30 percent so
I'm curious what the other items are in
the basket
that is waiting
these items you're talking about only a
20 I mean if I'm doing an audit I want
to look at 80 so what what's the picture
of the other 80 okay so the other big
item which will come to is housing
Housing Services is 30 so so
most most most households spend a
significant part of their income on
their mortgage payments and if you if
you're not a homeowner then on rent so
that represents a very significant
portion I mean we talked about this and
as you're well aware that's an
increasing uh portion of our uh budget
for many households so that's about a
third very important portion of of
the whole economy as well as uh
inflation
Medical Services a little under 10 so uh
medical medical spending hospital bills
and so on that's big
um and I'm trying to remember some of
the other categories here uh the next
topic is is new and used cars and I
believe together they represent about
seven percent so you know that's our
payments on cars and and the money that
we spend so now we're we're starting to
get closer to 80 when you add that all
up
representative fellows has a question
thank you madam chair so I'm looking at
charts and a lot of them the ones that
have to do with CPI they say U.S city
average
so my question is
is that the U.S average or is it U.S
average only of the cities and the
second part of it is are there any of
these measures that New England or New
Hampshire or the Northeast has that are
significantly different from the whole
nation on on the latter question I've
looked at uh data specifically for New
England region and almost always the
data I see the region tracks the US very
closely and that's that's generally true
I mean we we are a small region part of
the country so we generally track the
rest of the the nation fairly closely on
things like prices even even with some
variations of course General patterns
about how our labor market does
employment trends and so on WE track the
rest of the nation as well so I haven't
seen sort of big areas sectors where we
deviate from the rest of nation in a big
way I haven't seen that on the first
question that's an interesting question
the usual data that the the
Bureau of Labor Statistics reports is
the the U.S city average is what they
report as a headline number now you ask
an interesting question this is all
based on surveys and so I think that's a
function of kind of how the survey is
administered but how widely that
captures sort of what you might consider
non-urban areas is a very good question
I I don't have a I don't know the exact
okay uh shall we continue here and I'm
glad glad to understand questions I'm
glad there's a good engagement here
um the other big category is is I
apologize I miss someone no not a
problem call me has a question
absolutely yes please so just quickly on
Urban for the federal government
sometimes means as small as a five
thousand I think that might be right
yeah depending on do you know which one
all right okay so next category is uh
used car prices so this was also in the
news a lot
um shown in red is uh an index of used
car prices and then shown in blue are
new car prices
so what you see here is that throughout
2021 especially in the in the latter
part of 21 and early part of 22 used car
prices went up a lot very dramatically
um and uh
contributed a lot to inflation so use
Car Pro use car category you know maybe
four percent of the consumption basket
but if if there's such a dramatic
increase in prices then it can show up
in terms of moving the overall price
level there and you know there was a lot
of uh anecdotes people getting appraised
uh you know their their used cars
appraised at dealerships or these online
uh places you can go and sell your cars
and getting very surprised by the prices
that they were getting
new car prices have also been rising I
found myself in the unfortunate place of
needing a new car in April of last year
and uh the experience of buying a new
car at that time was completely
different from any other time that I
tried to buy a car
um and uh dealerships basically the
initial conversation was how much of a
markup are you willing to pay to buy a
car was kind of the conversation so that
is immediately about inflation so the
the new car prices are going up because
the effective price that includes all
the markups and and Market adjustments
are going to be reflected in inflation
so car prices have been going up but
again
that's been happening what's the most
recent Trend if you take a look at the
red line there uh if you look at the
second half of 2022 starting about June
or so we are seeing so it has stabilized
and then we're seeing a decline for the
most recent you know three four months
or so a positive sign so if that Trend
continues and and signs are that used
car prices continue to come down because
there was such a dramatic run up in
prices there there it's it's coming back
to a more normal levels that would be uh
they'll be relieving a lot of pressure
on inflation new car prices continue to
rise but if you look at the the Blue
Line the rate of increase is slowing so
it's not it's not falling but the rate
of increases slowing again a positive
thing for inflation so this is
contributing to currently it's
contributing to year over year inflation
for sure but uh as an Outlook this the
trend is in the right direction we might
not be seeing quite as big of
contributions to inflation from this
okay moving on to the next topic here so
everyone's pandemic savings are getting
smaller how will it affect economy is a
recent kind of headline from end of last
year
so an important
observation about U.S households and
when you think about an outlook for the
economy going forward especially when
you ask are we going to have a recession
the zero uh or next and how bad will it
be if we do
one one important thing to think about
is is the health of household balance
sheets especially how much Christian
American households have in terms of
savings that could help in the event
that uh unemployment to rise or there
were to be some economic challenges
so to think about this let's think about
let's Define savings so this is how uh
savings is defined in official
statistics you take household disposable
income
and then you subtract uh household
consumption expenditures and you
subtract other outlays and then what's
left is saved so that kind of makes
sense intuitively
uh so excess savings uh help households
get through difficult economic periods
that's one reason why we care about this
another factor is that if this is really
high and maybe this gets at uh one of
Representative questions earlier uh it
may fuel high levels of spending uh
because when you have a lot of savings
you might spend more of that and
possibly that could contribute to
elevated levels of demand in the economy
and lead to inflationary pressures
so Federal Reserve estimates that over
2020 and 2021 households accumulated
sort of unprecedented levels of excess
savings 2.3 trillion
why was that disposable income was high
so a lot of this was the result of cares
act American Rescue plan act transfers
from federal government households which
was meant to offset uh some of the the
wage income losses and business income
losses during that time uh but it it it
did more than offset so the net impact
was that households did have uh to see
their savings increase uh during this
period the other important driver is
that we can our consumption was low our
expenditures were low my international
trip which would have cost a good amount
didn't happen so all that went to
savings
um and then the extra sofa that I wanted
to buy for my home office I didn't buy
buy one so that went to savings as well
so things like that led to our uh
savings going up so that's lower
consumption and then other outlays lower
interest payments from uh forbearance
and student loans lower or interest
rates all of that helped to increase
savings during the time and that led to
sort of very very high levels of what
you might call excess savings comparing
actual savings to what you might have
expected based on historical trends
so on the next page
uh
the truck excuse me we have a quick
question yes please representative
Southworth
thank you for taking my question
um of course these are averages and um I
mean I'm thinking much of the population
did not have excess savings and so that
maybe the just like we have an upside
down pyramid for our business taxes and
things with the top really accounting
for most of it I'm wondering if that
same thing may be part of those numbers
absolutely a very very important Point
um and absolutely right we're talking
about aggregate in the aggregate when
you kind of add up all American
households how things look that's what
this data show here what's what is not
captured here is the distribution within
kind of the aggregate numbers so the FED
study that I referenced and and there's
a link to that study in the bottom of
the slide does get into the
distributional issues so very important
to note that not surprisingly when you
look at sort of excess savings we were
talking 2.3 trillion of very very large
numbers a large majority of that is is
held by high income households
that said when you look at lower income
households so this is based on some
studies I've seen recently and you ask
questions like hey how much do people
have in their checking accounts now uh
for lower income households today versus
what they had in 2019 before the
pandemic the checking account balances
apparently are higher so there's some
sense in which some of this excess
saving it's not going to be a large
majority or anything but some is held by
lower income households but it is the
case that a large majority is is held by
a higher income households
okay so chart of the right here is is
the fed's estimate of excess savings so
it peaked uh at about 2.3 trillion and
it's now coming down
some estimate that this number is coming
down by about 100 billion dollars a
month
and if I just take that number and let's
you know say that that estimate is
correct then it says that by about the
end of 23 we'll have exhausted uh the
excess savings and it would have kind of
returned to pre-pandemic kind of levels
yes sir
well as representative
thank you thank you madam chair I want
to dwell on that for a moment if the if
excess savings are gone by end of 2023
what does that say about uh the future
economy could there be recession uh
could there be uh uh instead of
inflation deflation people because
people aren't buying yeah so uh good
question so uh what would happen if the
excess savings that we American
households currently have
are exhausted so one thing people uh
talk about is that the fact that
Americans are sitting on such high
levels of excess savings is a good thing
and is protecting us against like very
severe downside risk in terms of a
recession because even if there were to
be a recession because of the high
levels of interest rates and so on the
fact that uh household balance sheets in
the aggregate there's a distributional
issue here of course High income low
income but in the aggregate the fact
that a lot of excess savings means that
there's there's purchasing power there's
kind of purchasing power that's out
there and so businesses will still see
you know some demand for their you know
goods and services they provide so maybe
the recession that's coming if it does
come won't be quite as severe as it
might be otherwise so what
representative pled was getting at is
once this is gone we don't have that
question anymore will we be exposed to
more risk at that time I think I think
that's generally right I think it'll
bring us back to where we're before the
pandemic when we didn't have these
access savings and so I don't know that
that's necessarily kind of a bad place
to be but we won't have the cushion
that's that we currently have that might
protect us against a little bit of
downside risk
representative legally
thank you this might be more of a note
to ourselves than a question for the
speaker but I'm looking at this chart
where it shows our savings going below
uh five percent yes
um and thinking about some of the
policies that have pushed these savings
up will also be coming to an end at the
same time and so I'm wondering if as a
policy as a
as a committee it might be really
helpful to have someone come who would
be able to address federally you know
what are those policies that are ending
and how does that kind of correspond
with these savings
coming down I'm thinking as you know a a
family of modest means you know how are
they going to be set up to face the
oncoming challenges of the economy thank
you
yeah I think that's a great idea as I'm
looking at all these slides I see that
they're dated September in a lot of
cases and we have to open up our crystal
ball very soon
and make some decisions that are very
important to the state yeah and uh would
there be any chance you could update
this information for us in the very near
future I I this is updated as as much as
is possible uh just given but there's
going to be a lag with data but if it's
helpful I I can certainly try and get
you the most updated data uh on any any
of these data that's that's of interest
to you that would be fantastic
absolutely I see a bunch of hands up
I'll start over here representative
fellows thank you madam chair
um I just would like a little bit of
clarification on some of the definitions
that go with this is that percentage is
it a percentage of annual income yes
disposable income how much of disposable
income is going into savings and the one
on the right is that the value of all
all stocks are all no uh excess savings
so the amount of savings that households
have accumulated a lot of this isn't
bank accounts for example it doesn't
have anything to do with that stocks or
uh bonds or anything like that these are
how much of the income
did we save oh during uh the pandemic so
the one on the right is
if you take then what happened on the
left you added up everybody's savings
yes okay nothing to do with stocks
they're just they're just in bank
um sorry I should be careful careful
about the stock issue
um
what's happening is you're taking the
data from the left which is and this is
saving rate at a point in time how much
of income you have uh did you spend and
did you spend on you know other payments
and how much are you left with
and then what's what's being done on the
right is just tracking that over time
just adding it up over time
so I take back my common by stocks
people could put that in bank accounts
people do different things with it but
it's just tracking how much of the big
saving increases during the pandemic
have accumulated uh over time that's
what's shown on the right so what the
left is on at a point in time on the
right is is cumulative and nothing to do
with what whatever you have invested in
stocks
that's correct the equity price declines
that that's not what this is about here
uh Senator Lang has a question
thank you Jason for taking my question
thank you for coming I guess my question
and if you get into this later that
that's okay just tell me you'll get an
answer later but is about debt right so
we saw a household debt increase uh nerd
wallet I think reported just today that
as of September 8 roughly is that
household debt increased by over eight
percent over the previous year and you
know a big portion of that was around
the Housing Industry right the
increasing their debt and housing prices
going up and and increased debt load I
think we're average household debt is
around 165 000 now at this point houses
cars and everything else so I guess how
does that play and if there's a slide
later then I kind of flipped through I
didn't see anything on debt a household
debt so I was interested in talking
about household savings we talk about
the other side of the conversation
household debt and how that plays into
our future
I don't have that here uh but that's a
that's a good question one one thing
that's very much related to that is uh
Debt Service uh household's ability to
service their debt and that metric
looked really good uh recently because
interest rates were so low so compared
to income which was healthy overall in
recent periods
uh interest payments on debt were very
low just because the interesting
environment was so low uh given monetary
policy so they helped a lot but that's
changed we're in a totally different
rate environment now so that service
requirements are rising so the portion
of income going to Debt Service the
other outlay category here is definitely
Rising as well so that's uh that's
that's an important thing to keep track
of
okay so I see that I've yet yes
representative
thank you uh I actually asked this
question two years ago of fed official
on and they told me that only once a
year I think it was in February they
re-analyzed the distribution effect in
uh the savings per household on
is that in this um footnote it is yes so
the the FED notes a study that I
referenced in the in the slide there uh
it it does have uh discussion about it
devised that the U.S households into
four uh quartiles top 25 in terms of
income next 25 and and so on and then it
it uh shows distribution of how much of
the excess savings is owned by each of
those categories and as as I uh
mentioned earlier most of this is held
by higher income households but some by
lower income as well is there some way
that
that quartiles
for the past three years that they've
got I I so I I can certainly I'm looking
as this is the uh burden that we're
going to have in uh the social on the
the
um
lost the word at this point but the um
Social Services requirements for the
part of our population the lower half of
our population that on may not that may
have even less savings than they did in
19 when
hmm as of this last February yeah I'd
sort of be glad to kind of forward that
study onto onto you I think it's
publicly available and and uh I'd be
okay so in my remaining 10 minutes here
I'm going to try try and see if I can
get to kind of the key points uh
remaining here but I'm glad for all the
engagement here
um
home prices so this obviously is a huge
topic it's a huge challenge uh Senator
Lang just referenced it as well
um
it's showing up in inflation home prices
are up uh year over year
um close to 20 percent
and so uh of course it's going to
impact
housing prices and the housing
components of CPI as I mentioned earlier
the weight placed on housing in CPI is
about 30 so what happens to housing
really matters
now
there's some good news here so
when
this is gets a little bit technical so
given the time here I'm going to try and
keep this at a very high level and and
see if
um
two-thirds of the weight that goes into
CPI from housing is for
owners of primary residences so
two-thirds by homeowners and one-third
by renters
now so what you need to do is you you
know the the economists at the BLS need
to track
rent payments uh by renters as well as
they need to do something complicated to
figure out something equivalent to rent
for homeowners because homeowners we
have mortgage payments but we don't we
don't pay any any rent so how do you
take what homeowners pay and then turn
that to something that looks a little
bit like rent that's a complicated
statistical exercise we're going to go
into that there but I'll just note that
there's a pretty significant lag between
the CPI housing metric and what's
actually happening in the in the housing
market and that's because
renters how often do renters sign their
leases
how often maybe on an annual basis once
a year maybe even once every two years
so when you survey a given renter at a
point in time what you're seeing is not
necessarily today's rent what you might
be seeing is rent from a year ago
possibly two years ago
and so if newly signed leases are seeing
reduced rent you might miss that if you
are basing this housing metric on the
total Universe of renters which is what
the BLS does they want the total
Universe of everybody paying rent
regardless of when they sign their lease
and so there's going to be a lack
between what's really happening in the
housing market rent payments versus this
metric that goes into CPI I don't know
if that was confusing at all but
so so what what do you really want to do
is you really want to track what's
really happening today because prices of
eggs because we go to the grocery store
every week to buy eggs you're seeing
real-time prices pretty much at any
point in time but housing prices we're
updating those prices like every year
so it's really hard to know kind of
where you are at a point in time so when
you look at uh places like Zillow and
and other vendors that provide more
real-time data rent is coming down
very positive sign because that says
that when the officials uh at the Bureau
of Labor Statistics update their data
eventually it might take a little time
maybe up to a year but it'll reflect
that reduced rent that's happening right
now so that I take to be a very positive
sign given the weight on this if that
materializes I think that'll be a pretty
significant moderating force on
inflation going forward we have some
questions for you behind you
representative
I have a question about the regional
nature of the data right if this
analysis in General on the Run pressure
is based on National or Regional could
you comment on the specific New
Hampshire Market because my perception
is that the most certain factors that
limit the inflation in pounding and red
rising in New Hampshire being higher
than visually I'm wondering what the
data shows I don't want to
um good question I've only seen National
Data on this point on the point of the
yeah well if you if you look at New
England data so the fhfa tracks New
England region and that New England
region has seen one of the highest
increases in housing prices uh so that
it will reflect the National Data in
terms of uh rent payments specifically
that I haven't seen broken out for for
you
foreign
I don't have that for you in this slide
but that's something that might be
available that that yeah okay
great
okay so in the remaining five minutes
maybe I'll try to get to get to the um
Outlook so there was an I thought what
was an excellent very informative
discussion with the labor economists
from the state yesterday so I I think
I'll skip the labor market discussion
but I'll just I'll just note this when
you so what do you think of the Outlook
I just gave you on inflation like what
what we just spent 45 minutes talking
about inflation Outlook what impression
are you walking away with I think I've
given you
generally a positive story that we did
see some very sharp rise in in prices of
different sectors but things are
generally moderating there are some
positive developments that we just
discussed what is the one area that's a
concern and if you ask chair Powell at
the fed or others they'll say it's a
labor market the labor market is very
very tight and they used used words like
it's extremely out of balance how many
companies are looking for workers the
number of job openings are out there the
recruiting effort that's out there
versus the number of unemployed workers
looking for work
there are so many more positions open
than there are available workers and
that's almost like a structural
challenge for the nation I think the the
labor Economist yesterday did an
excellent job kind of going over that
for the state in New Hampshire but as
they mentioned it's a national issue
um and so I think that's the concern yes
gas prices are coming down that's great
food prices are going to be coming down
that's great housing prices are coming
down that's great but if the labor
market stays as imbalanced as it is then
there's going to be pressure on wages
and will that lead to companies having
to pass on uh costs
to consumers in the form of higher
prices and will that lead to persistent
inflation that's kind of the biggest
concern here so I'll just I'll just ask
a question of course gentlemen behind
when should we get concerned
um okay the ratio of national GDP to
national debt when should we be
concerned okay that's a very interesting
question so I think maybe behind that is
a concern that you know there could be
risk of perception of risk maybe of of
the government being unable to meet all
their obligations if if a country is
issuing too much debt relative to their
National output so there have been
studies on this and it's it's I don't
know that there's a kind of a clear
finding on this obviously there's some
level there where the level of debt is
just unsustainable maybe at a very high
level but there are countries out there
that have much higher levels of debt to
GDP than we do Japan
uh and they've been okay and so uh it's
I would say it's a little bit unclear
where that kind of threshold is is is
there and I think it I think it's a
little bit controversial even in
academic circles where the United States
current levels of debt to GDP uh whether
whether that's a too high or too low
from a sustainability point of view I
think there are varying views on that
point
representative Rochford
thank you madam chair I'm just talking
about employment and and some of the
things that we talked about yesterday we
heard about yesterday and uh and the
workforce maybe certain segments of the
workforce not fully engaging in in
coming back to participation
so looking at what you were talking
about here with uh
the current state of excess savings
within the economy and having a burn
rate of 100 billion dollars per month
anticipating that kind of coming to an
end or normalizing at the end of 23.
would you is it safe to assume that that
might
Inspire or motivate or or or
uh get some of those people that are not
participating back into the workforce
what an interesting question that is
such an interesting question I had not
heard that but that resonates with me as
a possible outcome there when people
talk about so yesterday the discussion
really focused on like how do we get
Workers back especially sort of they
talked about the bookends the very
younger and and the older generation
that seem to have reduced their
participation in the labor force what
can we what can be done about that
um usual answers have to do with early
retirement covet related concerns
immigration maybe a little bit but I
haven't heard this specific issue that
maybe uh the level of uh excess savings
is is a cushion that allows some people
to stay out of the labor market but when
it does go away will that bring some of
the workers back I think it's a
fascinating question there may be
something to that I haven't seen studies
or analyzes of that but it seems to me
just as a directionally that might be be
okay we need to wrap this up soon so
keep that in mind folks representative
almi
thank you one of the things we're
dealing with is that on the inflation
may go down to even two percent but it
will go down with a whole lot of people
having a lower increase in their wages
than they have in their costs
which then puts more burden either on
the town if the state won't do it
representative there a question here
please yes there's a question there so
the
the question
is
how can we try to understand
this relationship between are we having
more
economically burdened people in New
Hampshire that somehow have to be dealt
with on
and if most of that savings is in the
top for 25 percent which is what the
economist of the FED two years ago said
he thought was true then uh to what
extent is there going to be a motivating
influence in the bottom 25 percent and
the and the bottom half yep so so
multiple things there um
if you look at who has seen the highest
wage increases
so one very positive development in my
mind is that the big rage increases have
occurred at the lower end of income
distribution it's in it's in the Leisure
and hospitality industry uh where the
labor shortage is really acute and and
they've had to really raise wages lots
of we see a lot of minimum wages going
up to 15 uh so certainly in
Massachusetts that's really helping a
kind of lower income wages
um the other thing I know so there's a
very important question about when
inflation does come down does that also
bring down wages and will that hurt kind
of workers especially kind of the the
lower income workers before the pandemic
uh before the pandemic inflation was two
or below
and wages were going up three percent or
a little bit more and I think hopefully
what what the FED uh gets us to is the
best case scenario here is here is
without a recession
we have a soft Landing where inflation
comes back down to around two percent
and then a wage growth similar to
pre-pandemic maybe three percent or
higher and I think if we can get there
we'll we'll be in a that's that's kind
of the ideal best case scenario that I
Senator Rosenwald thank you madam chair
um
the budget is Final
in June a very practical question
um so timing so
timing so the timing of when inflation
will come down General expectations so
I've provided some outlook here so the
fed's expectation is that in 2023
inflation will come down a lot but it'll
still going to be higher than two
percent if so the expectation is that
we'll see about a three and a half
percent inflation this year and it'll
come down to two and a half percent next
year where in 20 half percent it's
pretty close to their target two percent
and if if it's between two and three I
think the only people are going to care
about econ inflation is going to be
economists people like myself and I
don't think any of you need to really
worry about inflation or other just just
you know average American is not going
to care about inflation at that point
um
so that's the expectation will will we
go through a big recession to get there
that's the major question
all everybody hopes we won't have to and
I think because there are some positive
Trends I've shown you uh in the in the
in this discussion
um I think chances are 50 50. uh whether
we see sort of recession to get to that
lower inflation or not I think there is
a chance and I certainly hope that that
materializes that we don't see a big
recession to get there if there's a
recession it might be a shallow one
we're running a little out of time so
because I just want to be respectful to
our future speakers uh your presentation
has been awesome thank you could you do
like a little wrap-up statement or okay
great thank you great thank you so I
think uh the the quick wrap up is what
is going to drive fed policy where
interest rates go that's going to drive
the economy
and what drives fed's policy this year
is going to be inflation
inflation has so many components to it I
try to hit kind of the key areas but the
but the sector that the FED officials
are most focused on is the labor market
and as you heard from uh the state
economists yesterday the labor market is
very tight
and hopefully we got to a place where
some of the demand comes down so that
maybe the job openings the recruiting
effort by companies comes down a little
but um
without unemployment going up without
the economy going into a recession that
raises unemployment
um uh hopefully we can bring inflation
down to kind of where the FED wants it
to be over the over the rest of this
year and and next year and I think uh
there's a chance that might happen but
we might see a recession to get there
but
a reasonable guess that'd be my guess is
is that if there's a recession it'll be
possibly second half of this year uh is
is when economists talk about when that
might happen
perfect thank you so much thank you very
much
Senator Ling
has a sentence to say so we were talking
about housing prices rental prices and
Zillow was one of the conversations so
if you all look at if you go to an app
Zillow has a rental manager you can go
look at it and it's free you can take a
peek at it and it'll show you if you're
given region what rent prices are doing
based on current listings whether
they're up or down so I just happen to
grab Nashua Nash was down but I grabbed
representative always Lebanon lebanon's
extremely up so by re it has some
Regional rental prices that are real
time that you can take a look at if
you're trying to understand what's going
on in the economy overall when I look at
just the whole state of New Hampshire
rental prices month over month are
coming down
um but still they're still up over a
previous from a year ago but on average
by 75 bucks but uh month over month
they're slowly starting to come back
down so anyway just it's a good resource
if you guys want to look at housing
stuff
okay we'll plan to keep moving and we'll
try to take a little bit of a break
around 11 o'clock before our final
speakers so next up we have the New
Hampshire business and industry
Association and with us today I hope we
have Michael Skelton there he is as well
as Brian Murphy and Steve Dupree
wonderful I don't have all of their bios
so forgive me but Michael skeleton is
the president and CEO of via
and which is the state's leading
business Advocate and Statewide Chamber
of Commerce and previous to that he was
the president and CEO of the greater
Manchester chamber
and the rest of you I apologize please
tell us about you when you begin thank
you
thank you I appreciate the opportunity
to be here and uh I'll provide a brief
introduction to uh the folks that we've
brought along with us today
um the Bia as representative Sanborn
just mentioned is the Statewide Chamber
of Commerce State manufacturing
association and we've really enjoyed
being invited and participating in this
session over the last several years and
I think our approach to this session is
a good complement to the excellent
presentation you just had which had a
lot of great data and information
what we're going to try and offer today
is a first-hand perspective and feedback
and what we're hearing directly from
business owners and businesses across
the granite state and to do that in
addition to some comments I'll offer at
a very high level I've have the great
pleasure bringing along with us a few
Bia members who can speak from their own
personal perspective of the economic
conditions and challenges
that they're facing in their respective
businesses and then we'd be happy to
answer questions and and offer whatever
feedback uh that we can
um just as a an overarching kind of
introduction uh in our role as a
business Advocate as Statewide chamber
and manufacturing association we work
very hard to connect and listen to our
members and the business Community
across the state including working with
a number of other trade associations and
all of our local and Regional Chambers
of Commerce across New Hampshire we
conduct a Business Roundtable process
that's very intensive during the summer
where we host roundtables across the
entire State meeting with business
owners trade associations and local
Chambers Gathering feedback on
challenges and issues and potential
solutions that businesses are facing and
that helps us develop our our public
policy priority document which we use is
really our Touchstone guide and all the
issues and policy Solutions that were
looking to work with many of you and
your colleagues here in the legislature
on this is a pretty comprehensive
document that touches on a lot of
various issues I just wanted to
highlight three kind of main core topics
that we continue to hear from our
members on that I think will be useful
and Mr Skelton do you have copies of
that document I do not have copies with
you I know one was mailed to every
member recently but I will make sure
that we deliver extra copies so you have
some here yeah thank you absolutely
um
three main topics that fall within this
document that I just wanted to touch on
that really have been through lines to
our conversations and our roundtables
and I don't think they'll necessarily
come as a surprise to to anyone uh any
one of you and and certainly with your
conversations you've had over the last
couple days the first is Workforce
availability businesses in all sectors
continue to struggle to attract and
retain the workforce they need there's a
lot of variables that that have played
into that and in many cases businesses
over the last few years have had to
change their operations in order to
accommodate what Workforce they have and
what Workforce they can bring in
housing a fail availability and
affordability is a direct linkage to
that Workforce availability issue and
um I can say in in the hundreds of
conversations I've had with members
across the state when we start talking
about their Workforce issues one of the
first items they go to is housing and
they're hearing that directly from their
employees or the people they're trying
to hire as a barrier to attracting and
retaining them
and then finally cost of energy and and
energy the energy Market our Energy
Future here in New Hampshire and New
England as a manufacturing organization
we represent many of our states
manufacturers who are are among our most
energy price sensitive businesses and uh
also the stability and reliability of
that system is extremely important and
so there's been a lot of volatility of
course over the last few years in that
area and so that continues to be a major
concern
so with that kind of high level
introduction I want to turn it over to
my my colleagues here that have joined
me and I'm just going to give a brief
introduction then ask them to share a
few words about their business and what
their experiences have been in the last
year and some of their observations for
the year ahead and I think it'll give
you a window into what many business
owners and Business Leaders across the
state are are thinking about so I'm
going to start with Steve Dupree Steve
is a native of North Conway he actually
served in the house in 1973 for
uh for for two terms Stephen two terms
um he practiced housing and Zoning law
for 12 years as a partner at Solway and
Hollis and then he left to get into the
real estate development business he's
built over 500 Apartments of subsidized
housing in the 80s he owns and operates
uh 300 units still today and has
developed and owns hotels and Office
Buildings in the capital region so Steve
turn it over to you uh thank you good
morning uh I served 50 years ago I got
elected when I was five
but I knew that it was time for me to go
to law school when at one town meeting
in Conway just Lyman stood up and
figured out my hourly rate at 17 cents
an hour and said in a rhetorical
question to 2 000 people at Town Hall
you're a bit overpaid don't you think Mr
Dupree so thank you for your service
you're worth every penny and then some
I'll talk to you briefly about a couple
things first Hospitality just in terms
of trying to plan revenues you need to
remember even though we've had very
robust Roman meals tax collection it's
really a tale of two states when covid
came North Conway all the tourism
everybody wanted to get out of Dodge and
Roman meals taxes collections there are
tremendous but in the business travel
Market which is primarily Concord
Manchester Nashua Salem to some degree
Keen and to some degree Portsmouth
although the presence of the shipyard
really distorts that market it has not
come back to pre-2019 levels and frankly
isn't expected to get to 2019 levels
until
2024 assuming there's no recession I
based that on the fact that I subscribed
to a lot of econometric models and
Marriott and Hilton I'm a franchise you
both provide us data what's happened
with business travel I can give you a
classic case the fellow who organizes
the or has the contract to organize the
signs on the interstate you know this
Hilton Hotel this exit is from
Mississippi
he used to come once a month pre-covered
to meet with his Representatives at
D.O.T to make sure everything was going
smoothly sell a few more signs now in
covety didn't come at all now he comes
seven times a year because he doesn't
have to leave Jackson Mississippi on a
full day to get up here a day of two of
work and then a day back so he does six
or seven and he does the Rest by Zoom so
business travel is forever changed in
New Hampshire so when you're estimating
revenues and I'm sure uh Revenue
Administration can help you with that
you need to look very careful at don't I
would not anticipate any increase in
your business travel Market room and
meals over what you see this year and
maybe if there's a recession a slight
decrease I do think however that the
rates that you're seeing which got much
higher in the tourism Market it's a
yield management business like airlines
are going to have just as good or better
year I like to remind my colleagues
around the country when I go to a
conference that I'd much rather own a
Marriott Courtyard or Residence Inn in
North Conway than in the middle of
Kansas somewhere because so many people
can get to us and when there are
sessions we see fewer people fly and
more people drive to their vacation our
challenges are workers like everybody
had we applied for the lottery and the
H-1B visa when we came we closed the
Courtyard by Marriott for 15 months we
closed the Fairfield for eight months
down at Exit 12 where we have the Hilton
true we had that done in January we
didn't open it till September because of
the coveted restrictions but when we did
we didn't have enough workers and and we
couldn't open rooms we'd make sure all
our rooms were ready for the weekends
because that's still our busiest travel
time we get tourists coming through
that's why we don't want 93 expanded we
want them all to stop and have to stay
in Concord overnight
and literally we couldn't open rooms
Monday Tuesday Wednesday we didn't have
enough housekeepers the H-1B visa helped
us a great deal the other energy costs
are out there housing I'll talk about
that in a little bit but the other issue
we're having in the core cities and
business travel is security
from the homeless and I will give you a
case in point this morning before I came
over here I got a call from the county
attorney that a gentleman who has severe
psychiatric and drug issues is being
released from the county jail he was
declared incompetent to stand trial they
gave him medication at the hospital they
released him he has three times come to
the Residence Inn because he thinks
that's the center of the oligarchy
that's running the world and taking an
ax to our building we have no do not
trespass orders so we now pay 250 000 a
year for security Personnel at all our
hotels headed up by a just retired
Sergeant at the state prison that's
happening in Manchester it's happening
in Nashville it's happening in Salem
security is a big issue and what that
does is that lowers our profit which
then reflects we certainly will reflect
that in the numbers we give to the city
when they assess our property not a
direct cost but it's a tangential cost
in the business markets and then just
switching to real estate development I
will leave with you a little case study
I'm a pretty simple guy so I I started
doing Section 8 housing when it first
started sort of like being in the house
50 years ago and built a lot of units I
still have units in West Stewartstown
Lebanon Hooksett Meredith North Conway
Wakefield
and some other place and
the affordability issue there are no
easy solutions Mark Twain used to say
Everyone likes to complain about the
weather but nobody does anything about
it and unfortunately that's sort of the
housing issue but I will leave with you
and I won't go into great detail but I
will leave with you an example of what
the cost of one unit does and what it
results in in rent and the bottom line
is right now construction costs are
ranging between three hundred dollars a
square foot and eight hundred dollars a
square foot
eight hundred dollars a square foot and
that's that combined with the mortgage
rates has slowed down residential
construction when I talked to the
Architects engineers and I start with
surveyors because they get the first
call on development they're still busy
they're doing a lot of permitting but a
lot of people are holding back and a
friend of mine dick antagnos very
successful apartment developer just put
on hold a 200 unit complex in Lebanon
New Hampshire which has some of the
highest per rents because he can't make
the numbers work give him construction
costs the bad news is for you folks who
have to solve the housing problem there
is no significant
diminishment of prices for Commodities
building materials or subcontracting the
subcontracting by virtue of the fact we
don't have enough people in those fields
but the materials have not come down and
if you look historically I hate to date
myself but if you look historically at
the 75 to 79 recession the bank failures
up here 87 to 89 the 2001 recessions
2008 recession prices were going up
before they came down a little bit in
construction but they never go back to
the pre-boost so
um uh 300 if you can build a housing
unit apartment for 300 a foot all in
you're doing exceptionally well and I
don't know any developer Kim but I'll
pass these around but it gives an
example that to build an 800 sorry an
850 square foot apartment you need to
collect rents of
2482 dollars a month or twenty nine
thousand seven hundred eighty four
dollars a year and if you have people
who make an eighty thousand dollar
combined family income at thirty percent
they could afford to pay twenty four
thousand that's why the only place there
are a lot of projects being approved in
the Seacoast that's sort of a uh anomaly
because that's driven by the very very
high median wage created primarily by
the shipyard
so there are no easy answers density is
one of the key ones the Borderland and
tax appeal help a lot I hope you'll keep
that in place but density alone won't
solve the problem and short of deep
subsidies smaller units
quicker ways to permit construction
you're not gonna you're really going to
be working at the edges on housing I
will just add this one last footnote one
of the things that was added last year
was fishing game which is a wonderful
organization I'm a sportsman reviews
development plans now that has slowed
down
pro project processing dramatically and
I know they're trying to compensate for
it by assigning folks over from
Environmental Services but it is a long
delay and it adds a delay I'm not
commenting on whether it's worthwhile
thank you Mr Dupree for for presenting I
I guess I'm looking for uh you just gave
the 300 800 square foot costs what was
it before I don't have a reference point
on that so I'd love um
it was about a hundred and forty hundred
and fifty dollars going into 2019.
for those of you who visited or seen the
true Hotel I built that in 2019 right
before covid for 135 000 a room I just
had for the exercise that I knew was
coming up had it quoted again today
it's two hundred and five thousand
dollars
and I go wait a minute the Market's not
that good
um and you know wages have gone up so
rates have gone up we hire a lot of the
new Americans you don't have to speak
English you don't have to have a high
school education there's some of the
best workers we have our part-time
people get 15 an hour our full-time
people we don't have anybody under 18 an
hour and we give full benefits so you
can see why that with energy costs why
your hotel rooms cost a little bit more
and back in the days when I used to
offer them to legislators at the Comfort
Inn for ten dollars a night we can't do
it anymore
Mr Dupree there's a question behind you
learning and planning and what does that
do to you to the ability to provide
affordable housing in the state there's
no question the leader in this effort
about 20 years ago I remember the home
builders was Humphrey's Architects out
of Dallas I remember going to home
builders and they said we can do 60 to
70 units an acre
I go what how could that be but in
mixed-use development you can achieve
those kind of densities by comparison
when I tried to build a 24 unit USDA 515
family housing project in Hopkinton 20
years ago they changed the zoning and
made it four acres per unit so I needed
a hundred acres I mean so the land cost
your land cost and infrastructure
shouldn't exceed more than 10 to 15
percent of your total project costs so
when you double and triple density
you're helping you know let's go 20
let's say now it's 20 you're helping on
the margins that alone isn't enough
what's happened in most industrialized
countries not that I like to hold up
China is a good example of anything but
they build buildings much quicker to the
same energy code or higher with better
earthquake code than we do because they
compartmentalize everything so for
example in China they build a wall and
they put the plumbing and the electric
in it it's finished on the inside they
put it together and you snap it together
like a Lego set our codes don't allow
that that's nothing to do in New
Hampshire that's the national fire code
the national electrical code where the
inspector has to come look at it before
the Wall's covered up we are way behind
Europe we're way behind Asia and how you
build I would love to see New Hampshire
become on the Forefront of trying this
there are ways to do it and we need to
do it if you combine all those things
together then you can impact it but
Senator Murphy
thank you madam chair thanks for this
this is an excellent example very simple
to follow
um we have a lot of overlapping our
businesses and I what I'm seeing is that
anecdotally is that the pre-pandemic
employee is not the same as the
post-pandemic employee 30 hours is the
new full-time and that's one of the
reasons why labor Market's so squished
and I wonder if are you seeing the same
thing and are you seeing it getting any
better as we go forward yes and yes the
biggest Exodus was from direct service
business you know you can do I have a
son who works for a company and he can
work from anywhere it's pretty hard to
check people into a hotel room or serve
a meal or wash a dish so we saw a lot of
people bail out and find other work
that said I will tell you and we're also
in Property Management we manage about 3
million square feet off of spacing four
thousand apartments and Condominiums
what we're finding is that in the last
three months we're at least getting
resumes of good qualified people a year
ago we'd post a job for a maintenance
technician at 25 an hour maintenance tax
engine you don't have to know how to do
anything you're not an electrician
you're not a plumber you're not a
carpenter you're just a maintenance guy
and we would get no response at twenty
five dollars an hour now we're getting
some decent candidates so I think it is
loosening up a little bit I think people
have spent through what they saved
you've heard the federal Home Loan Bank
show that savings from all the coveted
relief that's been spent down and people
are back in the market but I think long
term people have bailed out of
hospitality and the only way we're going
to be competitive is we're going to have
to overpay to get people to stay in that
thank you very much great next I'd like
to introduce uh Brian Murphy he's the
co-owner of Boyce Highlands here in
Concord and Highland hardwoods in
Brentwood he's been in the forest
products and Architectural Millwork
industry for 40 years started at Boyce
in 2003 and purchased the company 10
years ago and just recently purchased
Highland hardwoods in October of 2020
2021 has a combined 91 employees and
Brian also serves as co-chair of the
bia's economic development committee
Brian
thank you
thank you everyone for uh allowing me to
present here today uh I think anytime
government can get with private business
uh only good things can happen uh with
sharing ideas
um
not to beat a dead horse you've heard it
from many many people uh
Workforce housing is a is a key issue a
very big issue one I'd like to at least
bring to light today
um
is attracting people to the trades
there has been and continues to be a
stigma in this country including the
state of guidance counselors
asking students that if they're going to
be successful they need a four-year
degree they need to go to college
and I'm a member of the national board
of skills USA
which is trade schools starting in high
school and these young people get
involved in the trades and with a
two-year
post-secondary education degree these
students can be making anywhere between
sixty and ninety thousand dollars a year
being an electrician a plumber and
working in our industry The Woodworking
industry and I think that we're doing a
disservice putting that stigma on not
having a four-year college education
there's a tremendous workforce out there
that they're they're going to college
and they're coming out with 100 to 200
000 in debt and
European or ancient Chinese studies
where are they going to get a job that
is going to contribute to the economy so
Florida has a very good program and I
would just like to start to start the
process New Hampshire
combined with the state and private
businesses
make investments in trade schools in
supporting students with incentives to
have their education partially or
completely subsidized if they remain in
this great state and begin their careers
here in New Hampshire
the governor talks about people
getting their education and then leaving
the state this would be a great
incentive to stay here there are a
tremendous amount of job opportunities
in the trades nationally and also here
in New Hampshire
we are down
14 employees uh since covid and what has
forced us to do is to we've been in the
forced automation now we're our third
year of a five-year project with that
and at the end of that we're going to
have the opportunity for Less employees
and
Machinery is great but when you have a
trained Workforce who cares about what
they do it's very important to producing
a good product
uh
the skills are aging out and need to be
replenished in New Hampshire and across
the repercussions from this we're
experiencing burnout from employees
working 50 60 70 hours a week it not
only puts them in danger it puts their
mental attitude in danger and it and it
uh puts a crimp upon their home life uh
being it's very important to be home
with their families these people are
very dedicated very hard to work
they show up early they stay late and
they would like to have some people
working next to them that they could
train so that they could all work
together
uh
if we ask our customers for longer lead
times
our industry is two weeks or sooner
we're the last trade on the job so to
speak at Boyce Highlands we manufacture
the finest architectural moldings in the
industry right here in Concord New
Hampshire our moldings are in the White
House they're in the Senate they're in
Harvard and Yale and everywhere across
the United States
where all the moldings downstairs and
across the street are and
the carpet and the Millwork so we're the
last trade everyone else has nine or ten
months to get their job done they're all
late so we come in and we we have to
perform
so if you go out to 8 10 12 weeks then
those jobs can be taken offshore they
can be done overseas and they come back
in
so we are all about getting it done
perfectly with a highly trained
Workforce and meeting or exceeding our
customers expectations
so
revenues are down because of wage
inflation and turnover costs that's
and then the the biggest part I'd just
like to say I'm I'm originally from
Finger Lakes region of Central New York
I'm proud to be a New Hampshire resident
I think it's a great state I love the
state I love the fact that one voice
counts
which today is an opportunity to
represent that I think we have a very
good business atmosphere I'd like to be
part of making it better
does anyone have any questions
representative Phillips huh thank you
um
that you're talking about you're
suggesting that there should be more
trade schools I'm wondering where are
the ones that you're referring to
because I live in Grafton County and I'm
and I don't know of trade schools that
are up in there in that area and the
second question I have has to do about
your Workforce do you train them on the
job or what skills do they if not what
skills do they need that that's a great
question
um
they need to show up on time and they
need to have a great attitude
that's the beginning and we will teach
them all the rest
we have we have uh very
very nice German equipment that we have
molders we have Sanders we have finish
equipment and we have so many areas uh
Steve mentioned uh
maintenance people our maintenance
people are the highest paid people in
our organization and they are people who
have all the skills of the plumbers the
electricians and whatnot and they're
they keep us they keep us running so as
as far as schools uh Pennsylvania has
many trade schools and they have
specific woodworking trades they have
Plumbing trades and these students
coming out of skillsusa which is a
National Organization of students who
work in everything from out outboard
motors to Millwork to sewing everything
in the world and when you see these
students go to a national competition
and compete and you see their eyes light
up with what the possibilities are
because people from industry are there
to hire them and put them into trade
schools right out of there
so uh we recently had uh UNH come and
talk to us and they talked about helping
the the co-investment and what one of my
the trades are much more useful to
manufacturing here in New Hampshire than
uh 18th century studies of Europe
so give give us give us students who
have skills that we can put into
Manufacturing in this state and it's and
it's a great it could be a great career
it could be as little as a two-year
program
with that comes a lot of infrastructure
and I know that being involved in an
organization called architecture
woodworking Institute AWI they're a
National Organization of accreditation
of quality of Millwork standards and you
have a whole nation of business owners
who are willing to work and step up to
the plate to help educate these students
in these trades
so it's a great opportunity thank you Mr
Murphy there's a question behind you
that's a great question three years ago
our starting wage was at 14 an hour for
an entry entry level position our lowest
wage right now is 18 an hour
and we have our skilled operators are
the number of questions I have
representative leapley next
thank you um
have all of the presenters names on our
presentation sheet I'm wondering if um
I think it's David Dave and Brian yes
can give us your last names and show
d-u-p-r-e-y
thank you my great-grandfather snuck
sure and and I'll spell b-r-i-e-n
Murphy m-u-r-p-h-y
thank you and just a comment that my
doctorate in medieval studies actually
makes it so I appreciate fine
architecture and um the trades because
of course they were using well spoken
thank you
Senator Rosenwald has a question thank
you and let me also offer my art history
degree
as if you if you don't want me properly
I said they would they would be
applicable in my industry
but I would appreciate the architectural
molding I have two questions if I could
um anecdotally we've heard that along
with the wage and burnout problems in
both hospitality and construction
there's
um the problem of alcohol and substance
use disorders and I'm wondering how you
feel that's impacting your industries if
not your particular
our particular businesses both at boys
Highlands and Highland Hardwoods we've
been very fortunate in that we haven't
experienced those we have and continue
to develop a family atmosphere at our
work so it's very open that the person
on the floor can come up any their
manager or anyone above if they have
issues we're very involved in in housing
if if we have an employee who has a
critical housing situation and they need
a loan to get into something else we
take care of them we realize we want we
want to have people for life and then
these days that's not something that's
usual people come and they go but we're
trying to create a skill level and have
them feel that they're part of something
bigger and that we currently are not
experiencing anything that I'm aware of
in those issues no but in your industry
at large do you hear I would say no
because our industry is uh very very
technically focused with very expensive
woodworking equipment which you can get
hurt or killed very easily I mean
there's there's great uh
safety involved in everything that we do
so if our all of our managers are very
highly trained to detect any type of
impairment when the employees come in in
the morning and in
since I've been here since 2003 we've
had one incident in that amount of time
where someone came in and paired great
and Mr Dupree your industry
um we we do a bunch of things we have
mandatory drug testing before you become
an employee I will say that we have
about 300 employees full and part-time
and a fair percentage of those our new
Americans conquered a resettlement
community and I'll be very honest
they're some of our best employees and
they tend to have fewer of those issues
because frankly they're just grateful to
be in this country legally and have a
job
what we've found though it started in
covid uh child care we have a lot of
single parents who work for us you know
like everyone in New Hampshire and the
compounding of having to try and do a
job and also be educating your child at
home or Child Care lack of child care
was a huge huge challenge so what we
found overall is that our HR department
has had to beef up and we're much more
of a wrap around service so we count on
all our managers our our groupings are
very small like for example at the
courtyard I think we have eight
housekeepers and there's a housekeeping
supervisor that housekeeping supervisor
is responsible not only for making sure
the job's done but making sure they
understand what's going on with that in
that associate is that associate having
a problem with sick child at home that's
gotta continue to make so what it's
required I think every business has had
to spend more effort and in our case
it's obviously more money and I think
true for any size business on HR
functions HR has become much more of a
taking care of your employee
holistically rather than just making
sure you're following the wage laws and
the i-9s and stuff like that and I don't
see that changing frankly the younger
employees who come to us now expect that
they expect HR to help them with
everything and that's that's cool that's
fine if that's what we have to do for
employees it makes for a better balanced
employee we generally because we're not
like a fast food restaurant that has
that really high charge we have the
Grappone Conference Center when we're
plating 400 dinners as a Hustle but it's
not it's not like as difficult as it is
uh as stressful perhaps although my
kitchen crew would argue and shoot me
for saying that
um as some restaurants so we've been
able to have it have we had some people
who have come to work impaired yes
um we tend to you know we've if we
referred some people out who a few
people over the last five years who've
needed really a strong intervention yes
but it's
if you create a good workplace culture
and people want to work there you tend
to attract people who hear about you who
know that we're looking out for you and
but it takes a lot more effort for every
business thank you if I could ask a more
general question or follow-up
um yesterday we heard that women with
younger age children are
disproportionately staying out of the
workforce and that
um
that social assistance
category of Labor is is among our
highest job loss and I'm just wondering
among your members of the Bia how
serious a concern is lack of access to
available and affordable child care in
addition to the wage issue and housing
that you've brought up yeah thank you
for the the question Senator when I when
I mentioned earlier that when I meet
with our members across the state or
with business owners
usually the conversation starts around
Workforce availability and Workforce
challenges and then it goes in one or
two directions as the one of the
potential root causes of some of the
challenges they're facing housing is is
usually there Child Care is the next one
and it's right there alongside of it
increasingly and
um it has uh become a a topic of much
more frequent conversation in terms of
as part of our Workforce Development
strategies an area where we need to be
thinking what Partnerships can we have
with other organizations and how can we
work with the legislature on solutions
that will strengthen the child care
industry that will see more capacity in
the child care industry
um I can speak to this myself I have uh
I have two children my my youngest is in
daycare and recently the daycare that
we're very fortunate to have a spot in
and have our children go through let us
know that it for all the families that
are in our daycare if you're planning on
having giving another child to let them
know soon because the waiting time for a
new spot was 16 months
and that and uh you know that just the
for families to have to manage that and
to then to your point about ensuring
that they can be available in the
workforce I think that is a huge part of
the labor participation rate changes
we've seen over the past few years and
there's both a cost issue and a capacity
issue in the child care industry and I
know that's a whole other topic we could
dig into but there's lots of different
entities that are looking at how can we
strengthen that industry and I think if
we're able to make some positive gains
and strengthen that industry our
thank you and thanks for the excellent
insights into what's happening and
your worlds and our world
um
this uh paper Mr Dupree it's very useful
and helpful
um
down two-thirds of the way you talk
about high property tax towns and uh it
looks like there's a premium on the
resulting rent that
would result in those towns of about 165
dollars a month I think what do you mean
by high property how do you measure that
and maybe you could
go into the property tax impact more
broadly
um Concord you know we have in Concord
we have a lot of tax-exempt property
and the resulting costs you know our tax
burden although Concord does a great job
managing that tax burden compared to
surrounding towns but we also have an
independent school district which sets
its own budget independent of the
Concord city council so those just get
it's a bill handed in the city and added
so that's a high tax burden town
moultonborough is a low tax burden town
because they're fortunate to have a lot
of lakefront property at a very high
value I mean the rule of thumb generally
in apartment
nationally if you looked at it it you
usually assume your base cost of
production it's another 50 percent that
can be everything from utilities that
you pay for common areas some apartments
they actually pay the utilities it can
be snow up here and you know Florida
it's probably greater land care but that
40 is actually pretty lean I think most
apartment developers in New Hampshire
will tell you that they run at a 50
percent
burden over the base cost of the housing
for maintenance Property Management
leasing all those all those things
um and the 300 a foot is is to be very
honest low for new house construction I
checked with three builders in this
market in the Concord Market because I
Was preparing for this they're quoting
starter homes what we would call a good
basic starter home at five to six
hundred dollars a foot and I can you
know I can I can tell you just can
commercial construction I just got
approved for 25 000 Square foot five
story building that when I looked at it
pre-covered I had a price quote of 250 a
foot and we've been working really hard
to get it down to 480 dollars a foot now
and that's you know there's still stuff
in the pipeline the surveyors are busy
the engineers are busy but they have
noticed that in addition to residential
construction dropping off interest rates
and costs being those two factors that
in the commercial construction it's
Municipal and governmental and
institutional work that's still very
busy but they're seeing that start to
thin out a little bit as all the relief
money and and towns have spent that
upgrading their schools or their police
stations and that you're seeing a lot of
commercial construction like I I do for
Office Buildings getting priced but
we're putting it on hold because it's
just impossible to make the numbers work
compared to where they were four years
ago so I think even if we don't have a
recession just for your planning
purposes you're going to see a slow down
start to hit obviously it's already
starting to hit in the housing market
because the interest rates if you're
going to start to see a fairly
substantial slowdown in commercial
construction just because people cannot
representative Southwest and
thank you and thank you for taking my
questions I want to ask Brian a question
it sounds like a great business I was
trying to picture maybe you can describe
it the starting person at 14 an hour are
they perhaps either living at home or
maybe even still under their parents
health insurance you know I'm just
trying to see with all of our housing
that's a great question that puts
everything in perspective the answer is
yes yeah they're generally a young
person who's living at home or have
roommates
um
we have had some pretty good success
with uh
people living together in recovery homes
and one person comes to work and they
show up at work and they say hey this is
a pretty nice place to work and then a
year later we have four of those folks
working with us so yes a lot of a lot of
our employees are living at home or
their dual income families who are you
know the father works the night shift
and the mother works the day shift we
run from five in the morning until
midnight so they have the availability
to work either shift to so that they can
work around child care and things of
that nature
uh so yeah when you you get to 18 an
hour that is a function of not having
people go and and flip Burgers uh as I
say that's a that's a starting wage yeah
at boys Highlands it's even more
difficult at Highland Hardwoods because
they're closer to the Seacoast in
Brentwood with your your cost of living
over there even higher yeah so we have a
great Workforce uh right now we are in
the uh hiring a
top-line manager who's going to move
from the Catskill region of New York
State
and we're very concerned about finding a
place for him and his family to move to
in that area and have it affordable yeah
thank you that's very helpful I think
like this chart
um that having an idea of what the 14 an
hour person 18 person looks like is very
helpful yeah and they they also see the
opportunity we do a lot of cross
training and we give credits and you get
an increase in pay every time you
cross-train for a different department
whether it be the finished apartment the
rough Mill the sanding Department the
Mulder department so they they can see a
ladder to getting
an increase in pay and a better standard
of living for themselves that's useful
thank you madam chair Steve I was struck
by one of the things that you just said
about
um
commercial building seeming to slow down
and I wonder
given the fact that so many businesses
were switching to
work from home
and some of those folks are staying home
whether you're seeing that the need for
commercial Office Space
is going to stay low and how that would
affect your job your business yeah it's
great to great and cover to be in
hospitality and Office Space
and not a big great horses huh
um business travel Hospitality uh you
know we were fortunate concord's a
little bit of an aberration where state
and federal governments are offices tend
to be it's very hard for the Bia to be a
great government relations function and
interface with you by Zoom all the time
you all lived through that during covid
so concord's a little bit of an outlier
that law firms that do anybody who does
business with the government's probably
going to still need an office when covet
started a lot of our tenants and we're
the landlord to a lot of the law firms
in town said oh we want to give back
space but then when they thought about
it they said we have more people coming
and going but we're probably going to
keep the same space and reconfigure it
but in terms of new demand you know
absent a chub or Lincoln Financial
moving back into town you've just not
seen those big big users although again
aberrations the the two markets that
really stand out the Upper Valley
Dartmouth has started to really
capitalize on the the brain power there
engineering school Medical school you
know and and there's a lot of startup
businesses that take off and then grow
employees and of course I'm the chairman
of the peas Development Authority and I
can tell you we're we're filled with the
gills over there and trying to find a
way to fit more businesses Sig sauers
expansion lawns's expansion very high
paid jobs but so office space I think
over the long term in downtown cities uh
is changing uh Shane Brady and Arthur
Sullivan who own a lot of buildings in
Manchester are converting empty floors a
thousand Elm Street for those who
remember that first they're converting
empty floors into Apartments
and just a footnote on that because I
love studying this five years ago we
were 5 000 housing units short today
we're theoretically 22 000 housing units
short but we haven't seen that much of
an increase in household formation what
gives
um uh I'm not saying this because I'm in
the hotel business and I have any ax to
grind with third-party rentals like
Airbnb I've used them but I think what I
know what's happened in Mount Washington
Valley is you're much better off to rent
your condo for one weekend a month at a
nice high rent rather than letting a
tenant take it for a year and that you
know again I'm not saying it's bad it's
create a lot of wealth for people who
engage in that it's been great to help a
lot of people but that has taken a huge
number of available rental units in my
opinion out of the market
we have we're a little short on time but
we have a bunch of hands up so we're
going to start with representative
palette and go to representative orrs
yeah Mr Dupree you uh caught my
attention I'm going to ask a 500 a foot
for construction does that apply to all
kinds of construction housing or a
commercial what that's housing right now
well it's 500 a foot if those numbers
are fantastic because you have a 16 100
modest home foot a lot of some that's
800 Grand that's and literally that's
why the trading market and Commercial
properties people are bidding up prices
like right now the hotel business isn't
great but we're seeing and interest
rates are high but we get we get
unsolicited offers all the time at
record high rates because they figured
out you can't replicate it for what you
can
own it
um and commercial construction
you know I I looked at the numbers for
the Merrimack County Courthouse that we
did what seven years ago and we were 300
a foot that would be a thousand dollars
a foot now for an Institutional quality
building can't stay there I know and you
know it will come down somewhat that's
why if you look at the home builders
looks at every every recession we've had
it brings stuff down some level but it
never goes back and I'll give you this
example I tracked two by four prices in
in in February of 2020 before covid a
ten foot two by four was three dollars
when covet hit in the summer of 20 it
went to 11 dollars
in the summer of 21 it dropped down to
450 and everybody thought we were
getting a bargain it was a 50 increase
but we wanted all you could get and then
in the fall of 21 it bounced up to ten
dollars and I haven't dared looks since
then but it's never going back to three
is it going to be 450 or 5 but even if
it's 4.50 that's a 50 increase in your
framing most Builders now who are doing
home building and even construct
commercial construction like I'm fitting
up a building for the Department of
Justice they'll only give you a quote 20
to 30 days in advance of when they start
because they can't take the small
Builders particularly can't take that
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so earlier you
mentioned you screen individuals for
drugs and that kind of thing so how's
that impacting your business and what is
the percentage that pass I have a friend
that hires in Pennsylvania
and he was telling me it takes 20 people
to hire two so he's got about a 90
rejection rate and I'm just curious if
that's still true or what you're
experiencing here in New Hampshire
hopefully it's a lot less I mean we
um we're not nearly that high because we
tell people when they apply for a job
they have to take a drug test so a lot
of people self-screen out and you know
to be honest we I mean we used to have a
policy that if you had any felony
conviction at any time in your life you
were not eligible for employment with us
but we've looked at some I'll say we've
made exceptions where somebody was
convicted of marijuana possession at a
felony level 17 years ago and they've
never had another offense great we'll
give that person a shot but it's not
nearly that high I you know again we're
probably biased because people
self-select and go I'm not going to
apply but the other thing that's amazing
though there are people who do apply and
take the drug test and fail a drug test
knowing you're going to take one I'm
going they they didn't we didn't not
hire him because of the drug test we
representative Almy has a question and
then we'll look for like a closing
statement from you Michael thank you
thanks uh staying with the workforce
again on we
we have had a problem in a number of our
schools including in Lebanon that the
school is oriented entirely towards
College as you started out saying at the
beginning on
have on and what happens is that a lot
of kids who feel like they don't want to
do college and that kind of career on
they drop out mentally very early in the
school process and they start doing
drugs
we had one of the first heroin crises in
New Hampshire I think in our area does
the member have a question please the
question is is this uh are you having
any more success than you've had in the
past with breaking through to school
boards and school superintendents
uh with respect to
their understanding that there are
productive careers for people that are
not going through college that's a
that's a very good question uh I as I've
recently become involved with the MEP
which I find is a great organization in
this state and getting involved with 8th
and ninth graders getting them all early
7th 8th and ninth graders it's almost
too late when they're seniors because
you they do tend to drop out
and we are going to take part in a
program that they have every year of
bringing the students to manufacturing
facilities throughout the state
I personally am very open to anyone that
I could get in front of to talk about
the opportunities in the trades to the
guidance counselors are doing what they
were taught to do but there are
thousands of students being left behind
and these students you know you you take
a farm kid who's got a good work ethic
and they have more skills and a lot of
people coming in the door and those are
the type of people we'd like to to take
and train and work with but getting
trade organizations to do that
would be a fantastic way to grow
throughout the state
I'll just add one quick addendum to that
um and this may be something that the
legislature can think about and and help
with I think our challenge
um with Business Partnership with our
Public Schools is how to scale it we
have lots of school districts in New
Hampshire and they all work
independently
there has to be more ways that when
we're looking for business Partnerships
we can do it at scale with many of them
at once rather than individually having
to work with each individual School each
individual District going to each school
board that becomes simply too much for
our business organizations and
businesses who don't have the time and
resources to be able to do that there's
a willingness to partner but we have to
find a way to scale it up at a higher
level
thank you
a lot of great information here we're
going to have to wrap it up I think
thank you
um
if you have any information that you'd
like to submit to us it would be great
because we've been taking copious notes
but if you have more that you want to
share with us we would probably really
appreciate that as we look for our
Revenue estimates thank you very much if
I could just add one closing comment to
um
it's always a treat for me when I'm able
to bring members to settings like this
because you can see the wealth of
knowledge they bring and I would just
leave this as an open invitation that at
any time during the legislative session
if the Bia can be a resource and
bringing members from various industry
sectors to come and give you a
first-hand account of what they're
working on what they're dealing with
we'd be happy to do that they are the
subject matter experts and I think our
incredible resources for you as you uh
do your work so thank you for the
opportunity today thank you so much and
members why don't you take a five minute
little stretch break and then we'll come
we'll get started again this segment is
uh the real estate market and we are
very lucky to have three people here
today Ben Cushing is the 2023 president
of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors and he previously served as the
organization's Treasurer Ben has been
practicing real estate for 25 years and
is currently vice president and regional
manager of Four Seasons sotheby
International Realty in the Upper Valley
welcome we also have Chris Norwood here
in serving his fifth year as chair of
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors now is that commercial Realtors
that is the public policy committee
chair excellent I apologize public
policy committee gotcha he is also chair
of the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority board and past president of
the New Hampshire commercial investment
advisor board of realtors a 21-year
realtor Chris is president of nii
Norwood group a commercial real estate
firm in Bedford and Bob Quinn is Chief
Executive Officer of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors where he
previously served as the organization's
government Affairs director welcome to
Ways and Means joint Ways and Means
go ahead
thank you very much for having us and
good morning my name is Ben Cushing and
I reside in New London and do work in
the Upper Valley I'm licensed as a
realtor both in New Hampshire and in
Vermont and basically practice real
estate in the Lake Sunapee region of New
Hampshire
you know as a realtor we've had a pretty
good ride in the last couple of years
sales have been rather brisk and we have
done very well we've had records not
only from my company but we've had
record sales in the state of New
Hampshire however there's a little bit
of a different feel in the air right now
that things might be changing and I'm
sure that's part of the reason why we
might be here chatting with everybody
today that some of us feel that same way
I know in my company we're feeling that
we're we're looking at different things
that might be happening even though
we've started the year off with some
really big sales high dollar sales uh in
the Upper Valley region at least that
have been happening
so you know what's what has gone on in
the last few years has been uh very
interesting in that you know my my 25 26
years in real estate
um you know the average days on Market
when I was uh a 10-year veteran uh in
the New London area was about 150 days
the average days on market for a home we
thought that was really good
if a house is on the market for more
than 15 minutes today we joke that
there's a problem
um uh and as you see on the sheet that
Bob I believe had handed out to
everybody the average days on Market at
least for the uh end of 2022 was 23 days
so home was on the residential home was
on the market
um that is a record for us here in the
state as is the median uh Statewide home
value
and that's part of the problem that
we're running into
I have many buyers that I'm working with
that would like to move into the Lake
Sunapee region predominantly New London
where I live and an entry level home to
get you into the town in London today is
about five hundred thousand dollars
that's a lot of money
whereas ten years ago that same home
would have been 250 300 000 dollars
so it's it's a it's a problem that we
face and I'm you know we don't have all
the answers
um we're not economists sitting here
even though Chris likes to think he's an
economist uh because he deals with
commercial all the time
um but we're not economists and and as
Bob and Chris will talk today we do have
some information from our chief
Economist at the National Association of
Realtors Dr Lawrence Yoon who we all uh
look at everything he mentions and and
use some of that
um you know entry-level values in the
500 000 range hurt a lot of people
you know that young couple that wants to
move to New New Hampshire New London
area it's hard for them to get in New
Hampshire is a very desirable state
you know when the pandemic started to
happen we uh I saw many many young
people and younger than I moving in from
the cities wanting to move to the
country but that's New Hampshire the
country and they had plenty of money and
they were paying cash six seven eight
hundred thousand dollars in cash to buy
a home because like they can now work
out of their house
and we're still seeing that happen
however one of the things that I was
talking with Bob out in the hallway
before we came in that I've always said
throughout my career is if I see new
construction happening new residential
construction that's what I I'm referring
to residential Crystal speak to
commercial if I see new residential
construction happening throughout the
state I think things are moving in the
right direction I'm not seeing a lot of
that
I recently had a client that bought land
in Newbury New Hampshire on a very nice
property that overlooked Lake Sunapee an
expensive piece of land
but wanted to build they're not from
here they bought the land they met with
some Builders and found out the average
cost to build a nice home in that area
was four to five hundred dollars a
square foot
that's a lot of money
you can do the math and figure out what
it's going to cost you to build a 2 000
square foot house
he ended up finding a builder from
Massachusetts that was willing to come
up here and build that for half the cost
um so those are some of the other things
that you know we're facing
um the other issue being in the Upper
Valley
dealing with a lot of nurses and doctors
that go to Dartmouth
um
we have many stories from clients agents
of mine rather that have clients that
can accept jobs at Dartmouth high paying
jobs at Dartmouth but they can't find a
place to live and or they're living an
hour hour and a half away and accepting
that job so those are some of the real
issues that we are up against in real
estate today
the other issue is that this is no
secret is inventory you all have heard
it you've heard it nationally it's the
same here in New Hampshire we have one
of the lowest if not the lowest amount
of inventory right now I think we're
just over 1500 residential homes for
sale at the end of 2022 in the state of
New Hampshire
now if you go back and I'm sure I don't
know if this is on a slide if they have
it in their packet I think it's in their
packet isn't it that 20 uh 2000 and 2015
maybe
um we had 15
000 residential homes for sale at the
end of December in 2015 and here we are
2022 we have just over 1500 that's not a
lot to choose from even though we've
seen home values go through the roof
it's pure supply and demand so we are
working on this on a daily basis trying
to come up with ways as to how we can
generate more listings you know it's
very hard if I said to each and every
one of you I could sell your house today
and make you
um five hundred thousand dollars profit
you'd all be very excited I know Tom
would be because Tom Tom and I are
neighbors down in New London and
Wilmette but but Tom would say to me
geez Ben that sounds great right but
where am I I going to go if you're going
to stay in the New London Wilmette area
you're going to pay for that on the
other end so why would you sell
or you move in with Ben yep you have to
deal with my wife so go for that
um uh you know right
if you knew my wife you wouldn't do that
um
um uh so so that is one of the other
that's one of the other issues you know
we are facing is a lot of sellers are
saying we don't want to sell right now
because where we're going to go unless
they're moving out of state right so
those are some of the issues that we are
facing
um you know real estate has been a has
been a great career for me I've
thoroughly enjoyed it I love working
with buyers and sellers
I'm a native of New London and New
Hampshire obviously I love selling New
Hampshire to people it's a wonderful
state to live in I'm very proud to raise
our Amy and I raise our two sons and my
folks live in Wilmot uh near near Tom
um so it's it's a great area it's it's
just very frustrating when people want
to come to our area and we can't find
them anything to uh to buy even if they
have a lot of money so it's it's very
very tough so with that I'm going to
turn it over to Bob and he'll start or
whether I don't know Barbara Chris and
he'll start his
PowerPoint presentation to give you some
more statistics so thank you very much
and look forward to your questions
good morning everyone would you take a
quick question before we move on awesome
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um
I don't know if this was just a a
talking point but it you you mentioned
now 400 to 500 dollars per square foot
to build which you know we've been
hearing and you gave an example of a
young couple I think that that wanted to
build and found that high and then found
a builder and Mass to do build it for
half the price how how is that possible
labor
yeah they didn't charge as much in labor
costs you know we've seen Lumber
materials come down a little bit
um but that with a apparently they they
knew this person as well so they gave
them a better deal on the labor is where
it really turned out to be you know and
I talk about that four or five hundred
thousand dollar square foot home we've
had a lot of builders in the Lake
Sunapee region that have had it really
good for a long period of time and they
built some places on the lake that they
were able to bring those prices up and
it's it's an unfortunate thing that it's
no longer 75 dollars a square foot I was
hoping that was some sort of repeatable
thing right right I don't have though I
don't think so but thank you
thank you good morning uh so my name is
Bob Quinn I am the CEO of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors and
I'm going to go through some of the
statistics and put some of the data into
into context
um I think we've all heard and seen in
the media notion that real estate both
in New Hampshire and nationally is
cooling off a bit and this may not be
the best analogy to make today but it's
sort of like saying yesterday was 105
degrees out and now it's 95 degrees out
so it's cooler yes it is but you got to
put it in context it's still a red hot
market so the first if I can do this
correctly
um slide I'll share with you is um
the New Hampshire affordability index so
this is something that we put together
to sort of give uh folks a sense of
how much home can a typical New
Hampshire
um uh citizen afford
and so again it's uh so if you had an
index here of 120 that means a median
household income is 120 percent of what
it would necessary to qualify for the
median price home under prevailing
interest rates so the higher the index
the more affordable
we are clearly now at the lowest we've
ever seen and that has been the case
throughout the year so we're down to 73
percent right now so that means income
is only 73 percent of what is needed uh
for the median price home so a lot of
prop a lot of buyers simply are not
going to be able to afford properties in
New Hampshire
and I also want to point out that you'll
notice this chart starts in 2005. so
this lack of affordability this slow
decline started about a decade ago yes
there was sort of an accelerant uh
earlier this year as interest rates
increase our and leading to higher
mortgage rates and that has certainly
been a contributing factor but it's
probably not the only Factor as well to
keep in mind
so other contributor obviously to
um
affordability as a part to interest
rates is the median sale price again
same sort of and you'll kind of see a
theme here uh over the past 10 years
there has been a slow steady Inc
increase in uh median sale price
starting
just after the recession about 2012 and
keep in mind for
eight years prior to the pandemic
mortgage rates were pretty consistent
you know say three and a half percent
plus or minus a little bit but even with
that sort of consistency and interest
rates you did see
both median sale price increase
uh and then
the next slide is the volume of closed
sales so this is probably one that's
most interesting if you're interested in
the real estate transfer tax so this is
total value of all property uh and the
yellow line is single family homes the
blue line is condo sales now keep in
mind Chris is going to talk about
commercial commercial contributes a
great deal to the real estate transfer
tax as well
so one thing I point out here is
throughout 2022 you saw on a
month-to-month basis so we always
compare January of 22 to January of 21.
you don't want to go January of 22
comparing to February 22 because as you
can see with
um their seasonality to real estate uh
uh there's more likely to see a greater
number of sales in the spring and summer
winter time people aren't as interested
so those decrease and that's consistent
year in and year out
in the past three months you will notice
that the total
volume of sales has declined so October
was down 10 percent November is down
about 17 percent December significant
decrease down to 25 percent
and you will notice that in all of these
charts the past three months there's
been something that's a little bit
different from the previous months in
2022 whether or not the long-term Trend
or not I don't know but clearly
something is is is happening undoubtedly
related to the the interest rates in the
economy
closed sales
so a factor in terms of total volume yes
median sale prices are increasing but
you'll see here that closed sales are
dropping we saw throughout much of again
post recessionary period year in year
out increases in closed sales I will
point out that in 2020
the pandemic year it was a record number
of closed sales in the state of New
Hampshire at 18 474 single-family homes
this past year in 2022 we were down to
um closed sale since 2014 in New
Hampshire
so there was a significant drop during
question is
um
how much demand is there still out there
for housing we see prices increasing
mortgage rates increasing is there's
still a market out there well Ben
alluded to it during the pandemic in
2021 it was not unusual for an open
house
to see 50 60 70 people walk through that
house in the first day enormous amount
of penned up demand does that still
exist so this I think is one chart that
gets at that which is days on the market
so this is from the time house goes on
the market until you not the closing
date but uh when you when the property
there's an offer on the property that's
accepted
so you can see again same Trend past 10
years that's been declining consistently
all right and now we're down to in
December it was 32 days
but this past summer it was as low as 13
days again sort of record numbers of low
um so there's still
as as Ben mentioned earlier it was not
unusual
um to see
this number being
90 days 100 days so there's still an
enormous amount of demand out there
something goes on the market it goes
maybe not quite as quick as it did in
I think the other factor in all of this
again same Trend past 10 years steady
decline fewer and fewer homes are going
on the market
and
we have seen that that really bought
started to bottom out during the
pandemic
in 2020 and we've kind of been bouncing
in the past two years still
historically low levels of inventory
both in the single family home Market as
well as in the condo Market
some of it certainly is going to be
attributed to the fact that
individuals Property Owners may not want
to put their homes on the market right
now because they have locked in an
interest rate at three percent so if
they sold their home yes they're going
to reap benefits larger equity in the
home but they're also now going to be
potentially paying an interest rate
that's that's twice as much
that's currently but you can see
previous to the pandemic the trend was
still occurring that we were seeing
fewer and fewer homes in New Hampshire
and inventory is a real problem
same thing argument months of Supply so
this chart shows if everything that's on
the market right now nothing else came
on the market everything that's on the
market right now would a sell how long
would it take to sell all of that
inventory
so we're down to about a month's worth
of inventory a healthy Market not an
economist but all economists will tell
you this it should be between four and
six months all right so we are well
below that uh the past couple of years
we have hit certain months where we had
just three weeks of inventory
and that leads to the fact that days in
the markets declining demand is there
they just aren't enough homes available
um this chart is just to give you a
sense of what's happened the past year
so if you look at it uh in January
um median sale price was about 14 higher
uh than it was in January of 2021 so you
can kind of see
um month to month in 2022. so the idea
here is
median sale price each month is still
increasing
it's just increasing at a slower rate
and the question would be are we going
to get down to that number being zero uh
next slide is mislabeled so I'll skip
over it's it this is really about just
demonstrating the past 10 years
um a lot of equity has been created in
homes uh and 2022
what we saw in terms of again
seasonality uh is very similar to
pre-pandemic years
2020 and 2021 we saw these wild
fluctuations we don't see them uh
now
I'll also bring up the fact that if
you're interested uh in sort of diving
into
your own communities statistics we have
that available on our website nhar.org
nhr.com also works if you go to the site
it's called Fast stats and you can kind
of bore down so I
randomly chose Bedford as an example
and you can see
how the sale price has changed
throughout the throughout the past
decade or so and some additional
information and I also randomly chose oh
let's guess it's not there that's okay
yeah and also randomly chose Laconia to
show you as well so
um you can see that it'll give you a
sense of median sale price how long
something's staying on the market
Etc so this is available for most
communities in in the state of New
Hampshire you can always check on it
um
if you're interested in boring down into
um deeper data on your community feel
free to contact myself
and we have access to that information
as well
so I guess summarize sort of what we're
trying to say here is that
um
and you heard I think previously the
difficulty in finding workers we believe
is tied directly to the lack of housing
options and I think we just demonstrate
that how the lack of inventory and
housing options for workers exists and
that that's a restraint on New
Hampshire's economy we need to work
together to try and find Solutions
um so I'm going to turn it back over to
Ben and Ben can talk a little bit about
uh what he sees happening
um
moving forward he's going to play may we
interject I see a bunch of hands flying
maybe this is going to be addressed but
uh
I'm wondering if you're seeing any uh
a change in who's buying
the stock particularly interested in
investors who may be
essentially converting
housing to short-term rental
use
and all that Bob and Chris speak to this
as well you know for me personally in
the segments of the state that I work in
I have not seen a lot of investors
um buying single-family homes
don't have a ton of apartment buildings
in the Upper Valley or excuse me Lake
Sunapee region Upper Valley has a little
bit more but we haven't been seeing them
Changing Hands much so I don't see a lot
of investors doing that in at least in
my segments I don't know what these two
have seen
I'm happy to get you some data actually
the National Association of Realtors
recently just did a national a
nationwide study on this and they looked
at it from every state
interestingly enough New Hampshire
ranked 50th in terms of investor buyers
into the into the into the state the
reason for that is a lot of the
investors uh that and I'm not just
talking about short-term rentals I'm
just talking about larger investors I
mean they're buying in areas like Texas
and Florida Utah areas where you can go
in and what they're generally doing is
they're finding neighborhoods that still
exist where sort of depressed pricing
they see an opportunity so they buy a
lower
value homes they fix them up and then
they rent them out at a profit those
opportunities are not really going to
exist in New Hampshire for that type of
investment property in terms of
specifics on short-term rentals happy to
try and get you more data on that if you
want to dig into it there is a really
good uh Source called air it's not BNB
it's called air DNA and they track
nationally
um
how many people are utilizing their
properties for single for short-term
rentals and so you can kind of you're
going to see that I will say that over
the past three years it has increased
the number
and I don't have a percentage for you
it's not a huge increase but again
that's going to be somewhat dependent
upon your community
Senator Lane
thank you thank you for taking my
question so my question is around
interest rates
um so again it seems like we're talking
about affordable housing earlier and
affordable housing is defined by the
cost of the house the interest rate and
the wage right those are the three
components as you figure out what the
index looks like and so obviously we see
the velocity of home prices in New
Hampshire and what it's doing and we've
seen what happened with interest rates
that's now causing a real bottleneck and
we're seeing you know again it was we
talked about the slowdown in sales
happening because no one wants to give
up a four percent interest rate for a
seven and a half percent interest rate
um
what's going to change what's that
looking like what do you guys see or
what's your crystal ball thinking about
for 20 end of 23 and you know 20 going
into 24 and 25.
sure well my crystal ball will tell you
they're coming back down to three but
that's not micro symbol is really what
all I do is change I think that's a
bottle yeah yeah absolutely you got that
right
um well you know a couple things and
I'll mention you know like I said we're
not economists but I'll mention what Dr
Lawrence Yoon our national Economist for
the National Association let's talk
about interest rates one thing I'll say
about interest rates that's interesting
you know
eight ten months ago a buyer could have
come in and bought a home and got a
three four percent interest rate right
that's almost like free money for those
of us been in the market for a while
however I'm dealing with Buyers today
that are saying okay we're going to get
a six six and a half percent interest
rate however they now know in most
situations they don't have to offer a
hundred thousand dollars more on that
house to get it now than they did 10
months ago at the three percent interest
rate you know even though they're at six
now so it's not exact science and and
math but they understand that they're
not paying more than asking price for
most situations in residential real
estate today and they know that there is
going to be the chance that they might
be able to refinance down the road so
um some of the buyers that I'm dealing
with are thinking that process they
still need a place to live and they've
been talking to their parents their
grandparents and know that six six and a
half is still historically a very good
interest rate historically we were we've
been very spoiled in the market in the
last few years where we were in the high
twos threes for interest rates
um so I I'm seeing that happen now what
is what is the prediction uh well
Lawrence uh Yoon uh who we we think is
um you know a genius in in our Realm of
the world
um he's thinking that interest rates
have peaked and that he predicts that
they will be coming down
um he he uh thinks that the
um eclipsing at late of uh 2022 is seven
percent he thinks that it might settle
at 5.7 at some point later this year as
the FED tries to slow the pace of rate
hikes to control inflation so that's
kind of his prediction so if that comes
true
um you know it's still not three or four
percent but if it's in the fives that is
really going to be very attractive to a
lot of buyers you know there still are a
lot of buyers out there that still have
to get mortgages one of the things that
we have been seeing in the buyer pool
relative to getting mortgages is the
adjustable rate mortgage we did not hear
about adjustable rate mortgages
throughout the pandemic one people paid
a lot of cash throughout the pandemic
and two interest rates were so low for
those that know what an adjustable rate
is right you can't get much lower than
two or three percent so the adjustable
rate mortgage wasn't even heard of we
joke about this but we have members that
are realtors that are brand new to the
industry they've never even heard of an
adjustable rate mortgage right so we
have to teach them what that product is
that some of their buyers May benefit
from it so we are seeing that the
adjustable rate being offered by some of
our lenders at a little lower rate to
get people into the house to help them
out with it being adjusted over over
time now you'll see this slide this is
from the National Association Dr
Lawrence Yoon so you can see the years
that he has there what his forecasts are
for unit sales in 2022 23 and 24. and
what he thinks the home prices may do as
well as dollar volume so you know he's
very optimistic about what's going to go
forward here now this is on the national
scale
I'm I'm a firm believer in our state and
I and I hope that these are more a
little more more positive than the
national scale looks for New Hampshire
because our values have always held
strong here in this state and I think
they will continue
so I'll turn over either Bob or Chris
whoever wants to start now
uh certainly so uh grab this microphone
my name is Chris Norwood and I am the
the commercial broker here on the panel
and uh you may see me from time to time
in these hallways I am also the public
policy chair
um at least until they kick me out
um so I thought I would at least Define
commercial real estate as I work in it
and so so everyone in this room knows is
I am part of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors uh which
predominantly focuses on residential but
also we have about two to 250 members
that Focus exclusively or primarily in
commercial real estate and as I Define
commercial the primary food groups are
the office Market the industrial Market
in the retail market and then you can
also look at the investment Market be
that a triple net leased CVS or a
multi-family investment or a
specialty-use product like a hotel motel
gas station Etc
so historically and I don't have the
pretty graphs because commercial data is
not as transparent so when you go to
sign a lease for a building it's great
that if I can capture that data so it
helps me with my next opinion of value
or an appraiser helps it with their next
valuation but you know leasing data is
hard to come by and on the sale data
there's just there is some uh
some trends that we can follow but it's
not as transparent you need a lot more
data to really uh to talk about that but
I am help happy to answer any questions
in that regard
so starting back in 2020 there was a the
shutdown right so if you look at the
second and the third quarters of 2020 we
were I we could should have gone
unsabbatical right there was no
properties to transact the phone wasn't
ringing
um people were in the office Market were
really trying to do what we referred to
as blend and extend they were trying to
extend out their lease rates seeing that
there may be a decline in the leasing
environment but a lot of the
um the thinking in that time was maybe
ill-formed because starting in the third
and to fourth quarter of 2020 and then
for about six to seven quarters as Ben
said it was pretty good business to be
in in commercial real estate
um so where where are we right now and
where are we going so if we look at the
major food groups and we talk about uh
things like the cost of construction and
the impact of interest rates I'll just
go through them real briefly I think the
office Market our employees as we look
at ourselves as a state where are we I
think for the most part New Hampshire as
opposed to larger cities like Boston are
doing a better job inviting folks back
into the work environment that is
continued to bolster the office Market
in New Hampshire are there segments of
the economy and segments of the business
Community where people are less likely
to go back absolutely when you have a
large office building of a single tenant
of hundreds of thousands of square feet
and you have multiple employees that can
share desks in that environment I do
believe their real estate footprint is
going to shrink but if you're talking
about the local real estate office or a
local attorney's office or engineering
those people are still coming back
because they're smaller offices
typically in New Hampshire and unlike
Boston we're not asking employees to
fight 93 for an hour and a half each way
it's a different invitation back into
the market so I do think there's going
to be a softening in the office Market
but perhaps not as dramatically as as
some of our neighbors
if you look then at the retail Market
retail has continued to strengthen and
we saw this in the early 2000s and I
don't mean to be doomsday that because
obviously there was a cliff there but a
lot of retail is is predicated on
interest rates and as we see interest
rates climb we have to be cognizant the
credit card rates climb but what we've
seen now that didn't happen in 2007
before the Great Recession is the
Adaptive reuse of a lot of retail
facilities so if you notice retail now
is no longer where I go to Just
necessarily buy my groceries there's
what we refer to as experiential retail
and I think that cities and towns and us
as a state needs to think about what
that means I take my kids out we go to a
bouncy house and that is our afternoon
then we go and get coffee next door and
an ice cream on the way home so that
bouncy house or that education facility
or that insert your experiential retail
here is an Adaptive reuse of something
that was initially thought to be a
grocery store but now it is something
else and I think that that trend is
going to continue
the next piece to talk about briefly is
the strongest part of our economy
relative to real estate which is the
industrial sector
so Ben you were talking about his
history and so I've been in real estate
now I think I got licensed in 2000 2002
somewhere in there and for most of my
career how much does it cost to rent an
industrial building I don't know five to
six and a half bucks a square foot day
in and day out day in and day out now
that same building is pushing into the
low double digits and if you want new
construction which by the way new
construction needs to be high Bay
meaning 24 foot higher or sorry 20 foot
clear or higher
those buildings you're renting out now
for double digits and it's the only way
an investor or or in some cases an owner
occupant can justify the cost of new
construction because construction steel
labor is so high not to mention
um just the the added cost of code to
build these buildings has been
increasing over over the years but let's
stay with a positive industrial
continues to be strong
and and that is I think directly
correlated to the challenges we've seen
in the last two years
I was at a meeting this morning with a
manufacturer who said I I need warehouse
space I am not going to risk my business
like I have in the last 24 months to
supply chain I need to know that I have
in this case he wanted a seasonal
business he wanted to have at least 12
months of inventory in his own Warehouse
that he could touch if there was ever
another supply chain issue so I do think
that we we do exist in a broader uh
political environment where people
understand what's happened in the last
12 to 24 months relative to supply chain
and on the industrial Side manufacturing
and Warehouse that's where we're seeing
the increase
that's for the larger buildings there
are still a lot of smaller industrial
that again continue to be strong I I
share Ben's view that when I see
single-family home constructions what I
see are title companies mortgage
companies plumbers electricians that are
helping put those homes on the market
and I do think that if there is going to
be a Slowdown in the economy I am
concerned about the smaller what we
refer to as the contractor industrial
Bays so that that plumber who has six
trucks and um and is right now has just
been putting those people out all day
long are they going to continue to have
the uh the income to pay their condo
fees to pay their real estate taxes and
so forth because they've just been going
fly I mean I can't get a plumber I mean
God forbid any one of us has a sink
burst
um but that's how I view the office
industrial retail Market lastly I do
just want to touch upon the invest
assessment Market because I do think it
goes to the question about interest
rates so the investment Market where
that may be anything from a four to six
to twelve unit apartment building or
whether it's a larger Mall retail
building or a single tenant leased
office or
um Pharmacy
the the largest single change that I
have seen in the last six months has
been the I don't want to overstate it
but the uh
I was going to say Exodus of investors
but I think that that's too strong uh
the uh Movement by investors away from
Real Estate not 100 percent but what
they're saying is sellers are still
pricing their assets at a three percent
interest rate
and investors are coming in and
borrowing seven
and there's no more room for an investor
or in some cases developer if I'm going
to build a new building and lease it out
to tenants that developer that investor
that profit margin is now taken by that
growth in the interest rates a quick
math I did yesterday was on a 20-year
mortgage which is traditional for
commercial real estate
the buying power for every hundred
thousand dollars of buying power that
you had six months ago you now have
eighty one thousand dollars worth of
buying power with traditional rates
now the the bright side I like to think
somewhat optimistically is that Real
Estate Investors real estate developers
do not have the same Horizon window that
single-family homeowners do my wife and
I just renovated our house and that's
going to be the house
knock on wood that we're going to raise
our four kids in
um but most res commercial folks have a
five-year balloon on their interest rate
so they're thinking of okay I'm gonna
lock it in and it may be 10 years right
depending upon it but they're looking at
a declining real estate interest rate
that they foresee forecasting coming up
in the next five years so I do think
that there is some positive news that
some investors are doing this they're
holding their nose they're taking the
seven percent interest rate in the
thought that things will be at a point
that they can refinance some cash out in
a number of years but again holistically
industrial is leading the market
interest rates have really pushed
investors particularly on the apartment
units to the side whereby we are seeing
more owner occupants particularly on the
commercial side the industrial users
they're saying I want to buy I know the
interest rate seven percent but darn it
I need that building because I don't
want to be impacted by the supply chain
so uh happy to entertain any questions
on that as well
foreign
ER
Madam chair
um if there's an economic downturn
what what do you see as the chances of
us having another foreclosure crisis
as we did in the last recession
is it high or have there been enough
structural changes in how much of a
purchase homeowners can Finance
well just from a
you know from our our Economist relative
to that what his prediction is that he
he predicts foreclosure rates are still
going to be very low
um nationally less than one percent of
all mortgages is what he predicts for
2023. so I don't think we're going to
see too much of that here in New
Hampshire you know it's
we obviously had the Meltdown crisis
that we all remember
um but over the last few years I've
haven't really seen that much and we
don't I don't think that that's going to
happen much and nor does Dr Lawrence
Yoon Bob yeah just added you know prior
to the the Great Recession
um as often referred to I hear from a
lot of Realtors you know if you had a
pulse you got a mortgage
um no matter what it was it was very
simple to get a mortgage
um the structural changes have occurred
and that's no longer true
um so you don't have people who are
basically putting down no money for a
400 500 000 home that suddenly is valued
at three hundred thousand dollars and
they're underwater and go into
foreclosure so that's not the case and
in the past 10 years if you see the
median sale prices have increased
enormous amount of equity has been built
up in those Property Owners so you know
if you bought a home uh in 2019 you're
doing pretty well right now in terms of
how much Equity has been built up in
that home and I think that's going to
change and that and that's something in
New Hampshire which um maybe isn't the
case everywhere in the country
and I'll just say lastly on the
investment front and I said I wasn't
going to get too statistical but prior
to the Great Recession you saw average
per unit multi-family sales be somewhere
around 80 to 100 000 and then decline
down to uh you know forty or fifty
thousand dollars in the Great Recession
and I can say from personal experience
that I was doing opinion of values in
the Great Recession driving around in uh
you know Manchester Nashua and the
lenders whom were my clients never set
foot in the state and there was a lot of
cash chasing investors that wasn't the
best underwriting I think the
underwriting that I've seen in the last
decade particularly on the multi-family
investment side has been a lot stronger
so that gives me a little bit more hope
uh where we're going great news thank
you
and and I'll also um just mention that
we can talk about
um as we're looking at where the housing
market New Hampshire is going inflation
rates mortgage rates wages General
Health of the economy
um but that that those economic data
points can't be the only reason for the
decline in inventory because we've seen
the study decline over the past decade
so there is something that 800 pound
gorilla I guess is sitting here which is
we as a state are not creating enough
housing supply enough housing stock to
meet the demand it is decreasing and
it's I think still an in a very a crisis
level when you're talking about only a
month worth of inventory available
so
you know I was talking to Ben earlier on
uh in his neck of the woods there's a
municipality up there that has taking
the challenge of housing seriously and
they are doing all sorts of creative
things both with Apartments
single-family homes and other ways
because
their businesses their local businesses
are demanding it indicating we cannot
find employees and when we do they
sometimes will accept the job but then
have to decline because they cannot find
an adequate home
so we have some municipalities who are
taking that very sincerely that same
municipality I was talking to there
someone who worked for that
um that's it that time the municipality
so the problem is the towns around us
have pulled up the drawbridge and they
are not permitting anything from being
built so it's all on our shoulders we
all value local control that's the way
things are done in New Hampshire but we
would also suggest to you as public
policy makers that there is a role for
the state to plan all of this or else
you're just going to have when does one
Town's local control start to impact
another Town's ability to control their
local control
their their borders if you want to add
anything
uh representative again
thank you madam chair
um I don't know who wants to answer this
but um we certainly know that there's a
lack of housing in New Hampshire it's a
huge problem and we need to figure out
how to address it is New Hampshire how
unique is New Hampshire in this or is
this a problem across the country
so it's a problem across the country
um
but it is a bit more acute here in New
Hampshire and I think probably it's hard
to compare New Hampshire to Colorado
it's a lot easier to pair New Hampshire
to Maine so if you look at Maine in
terms of
month supply inventory they have more
inventory available I don't have the
data right in front of me you know if
we're at 1.2 they were they're still in
trouble but they're at 2.5 2.6 or
something like that New Hampshire always
had a bit of a um
advantage
in many ways over Massachusetts
especially that Northeastern corner of
Massachusetts the value of uh median
sale price was always a bit so it was
more affordable that's not quite the
case anymore I was looking at
Massachusetts data this past week in
Rockingham County
you know uh your median sale price for
the county uh at the year end was 550 or
something it's in your packet that's
pretty much what it is in Northeast
Massachusetts as well so we've kind of
caught up to them and
I it's being around County
um the total number of homes that were
sold single-family homes in Rockingham
County only 10 percent sold for less
than 400 000
um last year
so the vast majority of properties in
Rockingham County are being sold for
five hundred thousand dollars and above
it's going to impact your first time
home buyer you know that's a very
challenging thing for someone to do I
will also bring up and I met someone
recently who who mentioned this to me
they were retiree they were living in a
community
um and
they just retired they had to downsize
can't find anything in their town that
they can afford and so he's like listen
I've grown up in this town of Linda's
town all my life I have to move I have
to leave the town because there's
nothing available for me
Senator Murphy
thank you madam chair my sense is that
of the many many factors that are
affecting the housing market and driving
it such
situation
that the influx of people we had from
other States during the pandemic was a
big was a big cause
um
is there any indication that they're
leaving have any there has been any
buyers in Mars or they just should be
playing for them to stick around for the
next
so yeah you know I I that's a great
question uh you know being from New
London small little town we don't have
enough stop light in New London but in
the summertime when it takes more than
10 minutes to get from the post office
to the college as Tom knows I'm ready
for all of them to go home uh meaning
the summer folks
um you know I I'm not sure if they're
leaving you know one thing I can tell
you is I know uh being on the school
board and the curesearch Regional School
District and and having a good friend
that is on the Sunapee School Board
a lot of families actually moved up
during the pandemic and enrolled their
kids in our school districts our numbers
went up a little bit as did centipedes
and they're staying they're they're not
leaving you know they had a they had
another house up here already and this
is their primary residence now so I
don't see a lot of people moving out
um once again
um you know I I sell the New Hampshire
experience to be people and a lot of
people want to live here and
the other thing also is because of what
happened throughout the pandemic you can
work from home now why would they leave
why would they leave
I think just one piece of data so as as
representative Sanborn mentioned I also
serve as the chair of New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority Ben Frost and
his team from New Hampshire housing had
done some research in 2021 and I don't
know if they captured that same data in
22 but what they did is they looked at
all the transfers in historic years to
find out typically how many
transactions happen from New Hampshire
sellers to out-of-state buyers
and again I don't have the data for 2022
but I share it from the increase from
2020 to
2021 was only around two percent from an
increase of out-of-state buyers and so I
I suggest that to say that I do think
that the out-of-state folks are mostly
in line of what Ben is saying is where
there are already folks who had a second
home and they're moving here the people
who are buying in New Hampshire knew I
think have got a lot of media attention
and and I'm not saying that they're not
there I just don't believe that the
statistics say that they are the only
reason for the increase in in um in
housing prices
I think those stats were somewhere in
the vicinity of 70 about 70 percent of
all transactions uh are New Hampshire
residents moving to another home in New
Hampshire so 30 percent would come from
out of state when it changed during the
pandemic maybe it went down to 67.
Senator Lang and then representative
Bolton please so I I I'm sorry I just
want to follow up on that this this
conversation so are you saying that we
we there's no data point to capture
because they already owned a home and
they may have made that now their
primary home and so there's no housing
data point to capture is that is that
your yeah for the subset that Ben
mentioned which are folks that
um were already had a second home that
uh moved up here I think the data to
capture and I spoke with folks
anecdotally is if you looked at school
enrollment records from 2020 to 2021 in
uh communities that are predominantly
vacation communities you saw upticks in
those areas
um but you wouldn't necessarily capture
that subset I.E people who already owned
thank you madam chair
um this is gonna get a quick one but uh
regarding that town or city that is
doing creative things for Housing
I think there are clearly some
communities which
um have met the
housing and um Challenge in a way that's
um sincere and I I don't it's hard to
point to each Community because then you
forget one and someone says well where
do I mean I think places like Exeter and
uh Lebanon
um are are making real attempts to and
there are others too I'm not in Dover
and there are plenty of others
um but I do think that the overall point
is
some communities are doing this uh and
others are not and so then the question
becomes is there a state role to play to
ensure that hey looks and everybody's
gotta participate in this in order to
meet this affordability problem
and if I could there are a couple quick
uh solutions to like exchanging of
development rights if you take land that
you would otherwise put into
conservation in exchange what could be
developed on that land into an area that
already has Municipal Water and Sewer uh
maybe that's a solution that could be a
uniquely New Hampshire solution that we
could offer to uh municipalities
to the senate members who are here the
speaker created a special committee on
housing to try to really drill down on
this so hopefully you will participate
in whatever they're doing there I saw a
hand on this corner did I not no any
other hands for questions
representative jinnegan
thank you madam chair I think this
message is for Chris uh this question is
for Chris
um you had mentioned that the
multi-family Market
um I think pre-great recession was about
80 to 100K per unit dropped to about 40K
per unit what is it now uh
for the class you know B wood frame
stuff it's probably 100 to 115 120. for
the class A stuff where there's a nice
Lobby and you know the the above a
builder grade you're talking many many
higher multiples because it goes back to
that cost of construction so I can put
on my New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority hat and I can say that you
know to build new construction nowadays
it's three hundred thousand dollars per
unit all in land soft costs Etc
aren't you
guys
um I I know everyone's eager to get to
lunch and we're the last I guess of the
two days so
um but just to sort of wrap up in terms
of getting into some of the questions
regarding you know how do we improve
um uh inventory in the state and bring
down affordability we do have to take
and we have reached out to and we've had
a lot of conversations with Municipal
leaders in terms of some of the
challenges that they face land use
boards what are they hearing from from
their residents and um you know one of
the contributing factors certainly not
the only is a concern by some
communities have is hey if I build more
housing
then that means we're going to see more
school-age kids come into my community
those school age kids are then going to
go into my school and I'm gonna have to
pay for them and so therefore my taxes
are going to go up if more kids come in
so several years ago we looked at this
issue we actually
brought in a an economist from the
University of New Hampshire and he
basically just went through every single
town in New Hampshire uh looked at what
their education tax rates have been over
the past decade and what their
enrollment and try and find a
correlation to it
with your Indulgence we actually have a
quick five minute video that uh if you
are willing to uh watch
um and then this will kind of explain it
follow and educating those kids means
property taxpayers will pay more what is
it really true two additional school-age
kids actually engage property tax
increases
the question is critical to New
Hampshire policymakers at the local and
state level because of reluctance to
educate more children is likely leading
to the state's growing house and
affordability crisis it seems to be
believed at least in some circles across
the state that if you build more housing
in a town and that brings families and
children into town the additional School
enrollment will raise local property
taxes
that belief I think is an impediment to
building more housing uh more affordable
housing for younger families across New
Hampshire
Professor Richard Englund former
professor of Economics at the Peter T
Paul School of Business at UNH reviewed
School enrollment data and education
property tax rates from over 200 New
Hampshire cities and towns in an attempt
to determine if more kids in town
inevitably leads to higher property
taxes
my research found that it simply isn't
true one cannot say that that if you
bring more children into town and they
enter the public schools that the
property tax will go up it simply isn't
supported by the data or by Logic the
school administration costs could stay
roughly the same does Debt Service on
the bonds that were issued in past years
go up no the the cost of Debt Service
stays the same if enrollment goes up not
all parts of the cost side of the budget
go up in proportion to even
Transportation costs go up school
transportation costs probably not uh
because they're they're often are empty
seats on school buses if you have more
enrollment you just put more kids on the
existing buses so it's not the case that
if more kids come to town that the costs
go up by the average cost of educating
the kids who are already in the district
in virtually every Community across the
state the number of students enrolled in
public schools has been steadily
declining in fact prior to the pandemic
of the state's 234 municipalities only
29 communities experienced growth in
school enrollment in the previous decade
while more than 200 saw School
enrollment decline
so as School enrollment has decreased at
property taxes in towns dropped in fact
the opposite has been true in many cases
as towns have seen a steady increase in
tax rates even as school populations
have declined
if you look at the decade just before
the onset of Covenant and what's
happened to class sizes what you find is
that in a large majority of school
districts across state class size
declined
what you find when you do that data
analysis is that there's almost no
correlation at all between enrollment
percentage changes in enrollment and
changes in the school tax rate yes there
are examples of of communities where
enrollment went up over a 10-year period
and the school tax rate went up but
there are also plenty of examples of
communities where enrollment went down
in the school tax rate went up
of the 11 largest school districts in
the state Dover for instance saw
substantial growth in its student
population yet had a smaller increase in
its School tax rate than six of the
largest districts with declining student
enrollments this provides some
preliminary evidence that student
enrollment is not the primary driver of
the local tax rate for public schools
the largest increase in school tax rate
came in Salem a town that experienced a
nearly 20 percent decline in the number
of elementary students during the decade
in fact only seven communities in New
Hampshire experienced both a decreased
School enrollment and a lower school tax
rate and many communities which saw the
largest drop-in students also
experienced the largest increase in
their school taxes the issue of
construction of Workforce housing and
the impact on the tax rate is an
important one and I can understand why
many Town officials in in town residents
are asking this question but I think we
have to be uh be look into the data we
can't just assume that if we enroll more
kids in the schools that the tax rates
will go up and to assume that is to
guarantee that we're going to continue
to have a housing affordability problem
in New Hampshire
so what are the long-term implications
for a town and a state with fewer kids
after all working age people generally
have school-aged children if the public
policy position of a municipality is to
keep children out of its Community by
limiting the housing Supply it should
logically mean that it will also have
fewer working age residents without
those workers employers will not have
the employees to expand and help to grow
New Hampshire's economy
[Music]
foreign
ER has a question it's actually a just a
procedural kind of question thank you
madam chair
um is there any way we can get copies of
this I would love to be able to present
this to our award we will uh we'll send
it out to everybody it is also on our
website front page
along with all this data thank you madam
chair
all of these presentations should be on
the general court website and there is a
link in the email you received from
Jennifer four if you need help with that
please see Jennifer who's around here
somewhere there she is
okay
excellent presentation thank you very
much thanks for having me appreciate it
wonderful
folks we are done for today great job
awesome attendance and involvement and
participation so uh we'll wrap it up for
now drive safely home and I know I'll
see my house Ways and Means members on
Tuesday Monday the State House is closed
thank you
and just a reminder the Democrats are